the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
champions of the elimination bracket
were
work with the American Cup in St Louis
with only one shot to stay in the event
the fight for survival was on two games
were not enough to decide a Victor with
both brackets going to playoffs Lavon
aronian survived three rounds in the
elimination bracket only to be knocked
out in the Final Round by Wesley so who
will challenge for the title Alice Lee
won her rematch against Nazi pakizi
advancing to the championship round the
final battle for the American Cup is
about to begin day eight of thrilling
Jess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 8 of the
2023 American Cup held at the St Louis
chess club we start a day at the
entrance of the Forest Park well if you
like to do your walks in the morning you
might see a grand master or two coming
out of the Chase Park Plaza Hotel well
today we have an exciting day filled
with explosive chess let's go to the
studio and start the action with Yasser
and Joe
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America this is day
eight of the 2023 American Cup the
championship rounds begin live from the
St Louis chess club Studio
[Music]
hello and our super warm welcome here
from the studio and I have to say on
this very special day because we have of
course the grand finals yeah but it's
also your special day yes sir my solar
birthday yes because yes it is happy I
want to wish you a very happy birthday
thank you and it's been an absolute
pleasure to be here commentating on all
the actions likewise you and Christian
have really made the broadcast a lot of
fun but so have the players and it all
comes down to this we are in the grand
finals and we have two absolutely
outstanding matches that we're about to
call Jovi let's start with the ladies
how did they get to the Grand finals yes
sir let's check it out in the Champions
bracket well it was a very close match
between Alice Lee and Arena Crush but
Arena Crush was just simply triumphant
in the playoffs and this meant that
Alice Lee got relegated down to
Elimination Brackets what happened in
the elimination bracket you know she had
to face off against Naji paikitsa and it
was close but it was Alice who was
Victorious and just like Phoenix she
returns to meet Irina
and missing in the championship match
will be the head-to-head players I know
and in the open section the open
Champions bracket in the open section
Hall it was such a close match between
the car and aquamura and Wesley so and
it was Hikaru Nakamura who of course
showed his price in the speed portion
and he was a champion bracket winner
netting ten thousand dollar bonus and
sending Wesley down to the elimination
bracket where Wesley had to play against
him well very tough opponent Levon
aronian and it was close once again but
Wesley so did Prevail in the tie breaks
and here's the championship match the
grand finals championship matching Carl
Wesley rematch
and tell us about the format of these
two grand final matches yes with
pleasure and you can see that the
tournament did separate into two
brackets Champions bracket playing a
classical 90 minutes and 30 seconds an
elimination bracket playing a rapid but
because this is the Grand Final the
players will be playing at a classical
rate 90 minutes plus a 30 second
increment ad no draw offers nice and the
schedule for today and for tomorrow is
as follows yes and we are going to be
treated to some fantastic games today
we're going to see one game played at
the classical time control both matches
yeah and tomorrow that's you know
tomorrow is where the action happens
because the match will be decided and if
Wesley so and Alice Lee do make a big
comeback and we're going to be in for a
treat on Sunday well there'll be payoffs
again and we have Christian in studio to
tell us uh how these uh players there
against one another in their
head-to-head clashes good to see you
Christian good to see you guys and first
of all happy birthday yesterday thank
you uh quote a great man yeah
baby's day it's Grand finals day and we
have some amazing competitors and let's
take a look at their head to head as we
are entering this final stage of at the
event we're going to start with the
championship bracket well the grand
finals of the open section that is Grand
Master Hikaru Nakamura versus Grand
Master Wesley so who came back yesterday
against Levon aronia after being
defeated in the blitz section by Hikaru
he came back and defeated Levon aronian
in the rapid and leads portion just an
incredible performance by Wesley so and
he came yesterday look at him he looks
uh refreshed right he's chatty today
with his soon-to-be
um opponent Hikaru seems to be in great
spirits he had a rest day as well but
let's take a look at the world rankings
of these players because this is what
strikes strikes me as a little bit odd
we see number five versus number eight
in classical number 10 versus number
three in Rapid but a huge discrepancy in
the Blitz World Ranking number two for
Hikaru Nakamura after I believe is
Magnus Carlsen versus number 19 for
Wesley so so and this is where the
difference was made in their first
encounter as well it was the car
Nakamura who took down Wesley in the
blitz portion of that match so this is
what I'm looking at for today and the
next couple of days in this particular
matchup but let's take a look at what's
happening in the ladies section as well
just two incredible competitors Grand
Master Irina Crush versus feeder Master
Alice Lee who as Jovi mentioned defeated
Nashi paikide in a very tense matchup
yesterday and right now she's booking
another meet up with Grandmaster Irina
Crush in their classical matchups two
wins for irina's zero losses and five
draws in the rapid match up two wins
zero losses and zero draws wow Alice Lee
never defeated Irina Crush either In
classical either in the rapid and Blitz
format just an incredible performance
for Irina Crush so far at the 2023
American Cup but the fun fact let's take
a look at how many decisive games we've
seen in this event we started off with
50 in day one but look at day 5 11 out
of 15 but 7 out of 7 decisive games were
in that incredible match that went all
the way to the Armageddon the match
between the defending Champion Fabiano
caruana and Levon aronian Levon aronian
was the victory in that one but what a
thrilling match that was we stand right
now at 50
4.3 percent decisive games well we've
had a lot of fight in this tournament
and a lot of fights still left in the
tournament and will be here at cology
action
thank you Christian for that and uh of
course uh the honor of winning the
American Cup is what's at stake which so
is a lot of money uh yes it's stealing
you're lying we'll let you say it's all
about the honor it's all about the honor
yes it's not about the money but it is
but it is and what is at stake and in
the open section first prize is 50 000
second place takes 35
000 and I have to mention also Hikaru
has already netted a ten thousand dollar
bonus just for winning the Champions
bracket and in the ladies and in the
women's it's also equally impressive
first prize of 25
000 second at 18 000 and Arena of course
has already emerged with a 5 000 bonus
for just winning the Champions bracket
and there she is getting scanned for any
devices or exactly
and uh if the if the champions of the
Champions bracket do win uh these
matches there will be no play on Sunday
there will be no playoff but there will
be a blitz tournament a 40 player uh
Swiss yes that is happening regardless
but uh it will be nine Blitz rounds no
draw offers fast furious time control of
three minutes plus two seconds and get
this includes players from local
universities and eliminated American Cup
participants
read world's best players there and our
full coverage of this uh what promises
would be an exciting event will be
starting at 120 local time for us and
we'll look forward to that calling
action I like I love Blitz as the
players are getting into the zone and
even though Christian you said this is a
lopsided scores and 13 years Young
you you don't discount that's the
opponent across the board because Alice
Lee is getting better and better and
better with every experience over the
board that she has she's getting closer
to the fitting Arena Crush we remembered
their last classical encounter when
Alice was white
on the board she was winning in that end
game managed to Swindle I renamed that
one but also Irina made one move with
half a second left on her clock so that
could have easily been Alice's Lee first
Victory against Irina Crush so
definitely she's getting closer and
closer look at this I was writer in a
crush I have to suppress a smile because
my whole career I was an English player
and in both games what do we have one C4
finally the training has been working
for both players one C4 now normally
speaking I played C4 with the idea of
getting a queen Pawn opening while
avoiding certain lines for example like
the grunfeld the groom fell players
couldn't get the setup they would like
against me what is it oh well I was
about to say what is it that Hikaru is
aspiring for when he plays the in
English he got E5 and is that the usual
routine move for Wesley that's a good
question I think Wesley plays a lot of
things E6 is one of them E5 obviously if
he feels a bit more aggressive but
supposedly E5 is objectively the best
move to counter C4 with just because you
want to fight for the center as fast as
possible you give me the opportunity to
fight for the center as fast as possible
yes let's do it c45
nice by the way after this move Knight
to F3 Knight to C6 is the main line
which it does
E4 is a very intriguing sideline I have
to say
I'm actually not getting any moves
update of my board ah E4 so this is uh
the Magnus Carlson line I I don't even
know what to call it because uh I even
though I'm aware of it I never I never
thought it was serious enough to give it
a name and
but when Magnus started playing it then
I was paying attention he was among the
first ones from the lead pack to play it
and he played it actually in the world
championship match so right
um in in the rapid portion so that was
definitely a surprise for us as well
Bishop to B4 Bishop to C5 those are two
moves that supposedly equalize the game
and if you remember this was played in
this uh match between beg him and then
Silva and then so I played the move D6
which is very passive allows D4
get the bishop out which he did Wesley
knows exactly what to do
the position is quite dry I have to say
after Bishop B4 and then D6 white is
going to be able to get the dark Square
Bishops A3 Bishop C5 maybe Knight A4 at
the right moment but in general it's not
enough so I'm curious to see what Hikaru
will be bringing to the table today
because once again I I personally
haven't found an advantage for white and
I analyzed this position quite a lot uh
for me the question is since you said my
Bishop's going to get hunted down I
might as well capture the Knight and at
least inflict a little bit of damage
Right double up the pawns uh in my view
once I've doubled up the pawns the only
thing that white has as a break that
makes any sense is the moves F4 and C5
and I don't think that those are coming
anytime soon this is all still standard
Theory uh Christian after Bishop takes
C3 and B take C3 is not considered to be
a good move no it's not considered no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
because A3 Bishop to C5 um Bishop takes
C3 take on C3 I think you just don't
give the bishop in a way that you want
to give the bishop now I have there's
more imbalances in the position and
perhaps this is something that black is
trying to avoid there's the B file open
we have a D4 supported by the pawn on C3
so there's a way in which white is going
to be able to defend upon E4 with the
move Queen to C2 maybe perhaps even G3
and Bishop to G2 and then at the right
moment play the move uh D4 and you
cannot recapture on D4 because if I do
manage to take back with the c pawn and
create this beautiful Center that's
going to be problematic so in general
black doesn't shies away from taking on
C3 with the bishop goes Bishop to C5
this is what we see right now okay I was
just gonna say doesn't this remind you
of a very low pistol chiggering
variation but with colors reversed Isn't
that cool triggering
[Laughter]
Grand Masters always do that they they
they they they make these comparisons
doesn't this look like a special cough
doesn't this look like a French what are
the uh pluses and minuses yes but I hear
you loud and clear yes chigore and
indeed yeah
five and a play continued uh b2b4 b2b4
that as just as he said hunting down as
you need to do this type of stuff and
then this imbalance will result in a
half open a file for black now well
Bishop to D4 is the main movie by far
yes far even
so that after Knight takes night takes
uh you're saying this night is a little
bit offside huh yeah Bishop to D4 is one
of the options Bishop to G4 is also an
option that was exactly what I wanted to
ask you Bishop to G4 catches my eye
because you know the moment I put my
knight on D4 I'm a happy camper right so
I assume the line would go tags takes
Bishop E3 or Bishop B2 Bishop E3 makes
more sense
Bishop E2 makes it should be two so if I
take this animal
Bishop B2 because you have the defense
yeah you have to defend against Knight
takes beef yes
okay and I was going in the same
direction here how how good or bad how
how do we evaluate I mean a lot of
pieces just came on off the board
doesn't black have a an easy equality
it's supposed to be very easy yes yes
you have to take that can I just point
out
yes please do oh it caught your eye did
it what's that well if you try to defend
the board with C5 oh you one always has
to remember this Old Chestnut absolutely
uh the night is no longer pinned and
Knight takes D4 I think I probably fell
for that like a dozen times before it
really conked me on the head it said
right let's not do that again anymore
but surely yeah Bishop takes F3 and
something these with the position so
closed all 16 pawns on the board uh
Bishop versus knight I don't think the
Knight is in any way inferior by the way
Bishop to G4 was played that's Wesley's
option
yes but that yeah that was the first
move that caught my eye because I wasn't
afraid of Knight takes
uh six I was thinking a takes B6 and
your knight takes B4 suddenly uh I'm the
first to make a threat yeah yeah exactly
yeah
close
one thing I have noticed about hikaru's
match strategy especially when it comes
to playing Wesley is he wants to take it
to the playoffs yes yeah you know we saw
how Superior it was in the blitz you
know in Wesley almost didn't have a
chance right but in the rap but in the
Rapids that was a different size it
could easily have gone the other way
yeah yeah yeah well in the rapid not so
much in fact and I've noticed winning he
was winning and Hikaru actually dropped
to number 10 in the world in the live
rating list in the rapid portion I have
no idea how that happened because Hikaru
was always among the top three but in
the blitz portion if we go all the way
to the blitz that were the big
discrepancy lies number two versus
number 19 I mean you're barely making
top 20 as Wesley so yeah I I think this
is a clear strategy a loophole that
Hikaru could be trying to take advantage
of try
shorter the time control and you can do
that by drawing in the classical and
maybe managing to survive the blitz or
the rapid excuse me and then take it to
the blitz where Wesley has been shaky I
have to say the shorter the time control
goes whenever we see Wesley down to his
last minute last few seconds that's when
he starts to make pretty serious
mistakes
exactly by the way we did see the move
Bishop G4 Bishop E2 Munch Munch and
finally we're caught up to the players
Knight takes B6 and anticipating a takes
B6 two nights versus two Bishops but
those two Bishops are not going to last
I'm going to take this
if you were to develop the bishop the
dot Square Bishop for example Bishop E3
or Bishop B2
and then would black just go cemento
with C5
yes that's that that's definitely a
major Choice yeah
do you I I'm I'm thinking you know once
I take this bishop off the board and I
deny you the advantage of the two
Bishops in a closed position uh I don't
think the Knight is inferior at all to
the bishop also a definition of a closed
position is very simple close positions
are when 32 uh eight is probably 16
pawns are on the board you have your
eight pawns I have my eight pawns closed
position half open position a single
trade of Pawn open position two pawns
have been traded off the board then the
positions open that's when the Bishops
shine and they say right here we go so
I'm eliminating this light Square Bishop
with the move Knight takes F3 if I'm
playing in a Swiss I don't trade the
pieces okay because I have to win but
how are you going to win this yeah I'll
play for
um
C6 and D5 or I'll play for uh in a dream
world
Rook A7 or queen A8 triple on the a file
the and uh attacked upon them but uh I
mean I for me White's plan is so much
simpler you know Wise plan is just a
castle step back with a light Square
Bishop okay let's do it
put me to the test indeed yeah you go
for that plan I'm going for your pond
baby give me your pawns uh I worry if I
have a solution for that because if I go
I don't know G3 G3 okay so now I see
that you are in fact uh planning to
retreat your Bishop followed by F4 and
that's kind of disconcerting so I'll
take it off and I'll go okay and this is
this was my grand plan of Defense
goes back to C1 wow um seizing the
defenses but you know I have plans for
the road The Rook will come up to A2 and
Sliders you know when I've broken open
the position with F4 okay okay I'm ready
to pounce I I get that I I kind of like
that and I have put my queen on a
wayward square that that that's for sure
so probably it means just here I'll I'll
use the I'll use the uh oops uh yeah G3
I'll use the queen in a nicer way I'll
put the queen let's say here and I'll
put this so you'll have to play your
yeah
regardless Rook over Bishop here now
normally speaking whenever I I have
double pawns I am
looking to trade them off I do feel that
double pawns are a weakness and so in
this particular position I would aspire
to play the move B6 B5 sometimes when I
have double pawns on the king side I'd
rather like them right I'm not trying to
trade them off but in this case I feel
kind of balanced and I can understand
why somebody might like White's position
or Black's position
um take us to the Alice Lee game if you
uh will uh Christian absolutely and you
remember I told you about this movie E4
yeah this came on the board in today's
game between uh ironic Russian Alice Lee
she did play the move E4 Nitro G5 and by
the way this is when Irina started
thinking about the position so it
doesn't seem like she's very uh familiar
with the structure nitrog5 C6 giving up
the pawn on e4 you have a couple of ways
in which you can capture this Pawn on e4
you can do it right away with Knight
takes C4 or you can wait with this
smooth Quint way for it's all about this
idea of black playing the move D5 and
taking the center taking control of the
center if you do go Queen to A4 D5
doesn't really work because you just
simply take and now you cannot recapture
back on D5 so what you have to do in
this situation is either defend the pawn
with the move Queen to E7 either play
the move B5 and this is the one that I
usually favor and I really like this
idea of B5 take and now play the move D5
if you take you're already in a very
very bad position after the move Queen
to B6 you don't want to take as many
pawns so Queen to E7 by the way it's
also an idea at this point and now I'm
retreating I closed up the bishopone f8
now you have to spend a few moves to get
that Bishop out Queen to E5 and then get
the bishop out also the idea is that you
cannot play D5 because I take take and
now I take on D5 guess what surprise
surprise the bishop C8 is hanging you
take I take on C8 and this is a very bad
position for a black close to pretty
much losing at this
so what can you do in this position once
again this idea of B5 followed by D5 is
an option but she did not play Queen to
A4 she well I mean you see a free Pawn
on knee for a centralized Pawn like this
you you want to take it especially if
you don't know uh the ins and outs of
the position this is the natural
response take only four take on e4 D5
this is what we have in the position
right now in general you want to take
because if you don't then I have ideas
of even taking on C4
reestablishing the material balance and
that position is more or less okay for
black so you want to take take it has
its trade-off this exchange because now
my knight comes to C6 in one move and C6
is a very very good position for tonight
can potentially try to land on C2 via B4
or D4 Knight to G3 is the main line and
now H5 will surely going to see this
Relentless surely we're going to see
this if she goes with the Knight to a G3
because this is the topical Main Line
This is one Pitfall that Irina needs to
avoid after the movie E3 makes a lot of
sense make some space for Knight H4 it
is very tempting to give this check
first
Bishop to B5 and say that after that I'm
going to go Knight to E2 I'm going to
Castle I finish my development and I'm
doing fine you're not doing fine because
you're actually getting killed on the
king side on the light squares H3 at
this point and once you go G3 and Castle
I'm going to have ideas of Queen F3
Queen F6 Queen F3 you're in big big
trouble in this position and if I
remember correctly you have to be
extremely precise not to get checkmated
you do not want to see this on the board
as white but it's very tempting I'm
telling you whenever you play E3 and you
see this check on B5 get one more piece
out very very tempting she has to do
this
after A3 H4 she has to go back to E2 it
looks ugly but slowly slowly you will
get your pieces out you're going to go
D4 Knight to F4 or Knight to C3 Queen to
F3 get the bishop out and play the
position as is
still a lot of compensation for black
and Alice Lee knows exactly what she's
doing she created a very early on
imbalance in the position I have my eyes
on this game guys because this is going
to catch fire and we do have that trade
on D5 as you prescribed it really on the
board
Arena following the uh
we're going to ch5
yes I like this Relentless thing because
you don't want white to just go E3
Bishop E2 and consolidate but you want
to keep the pressure you want to keep
the initiative H5 H4 H3 that sure makes
a lot of sense to me and I was going to
ask if you do something Daft because you
know Christian was talking about playing
E3 yes if you just were like oh I don't
want that pawn to get to H4 if I go H5
myself then presumably the bishop will
park itself on G4 and that's difficult
to develop right that's right that's
that's very good point and actually
after Bishop to G4
it's already bad for white black is
better right now right is it even it's
just that it's it's just stop it's it's
really good because like whoa and you
really don't want to take that away yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it glazed over don't
play F3 there
um no she played the E3 E3 yeah yeah
okay this is the moment after the move
H4 which is going to be very tempting to
play Bishop B5 so I'm curious to see
whether she will play Bishop B5 or
Knight to E2 no I'm sure she's she's
gonna play Knight E2 just because what
you said it's it's so uh straightforward
that you know with the bishop missing
from F1 H3 is obviously all those light
squares on the inside are just so weak
you have to leave your Bishop back on F1
but then the question was if she does
leave purpose back on F1 how do you keep
up that Relentless pressure I'm not sure
the move H3 three is what you wanted no
just Knight F4 and suddenly White's the
one who's got the development right get
the pieces out just go Knight C6 Bishop
D6 okay so how are you going to I'm
doing it slowly slowly H3 I'm assuming
Bishop to decision and let's say just D3
and I'm gonna try to
you know slowly slowly unwind and he I
admit that you do have Castle yeah
pretty decent pressure for a pawn bishop
D2 yeah and Bishop C3 is on my agenda
well I have ideas of D4 in that case
exactly that was what I thought you were
going to have to do and I was more or
less asking
at least with my Pawn on H3
you don't have Bishop G4 you know but
how do you continue your development I
go Queen F6 queen I'm going to give one
Pawn back that's for sure that's okay
but then you're gonna you're also
running down of getting checkmated yeah
I see so the initiative despite the fact
that we exchanged a lot of pieces
doesn't stop
remarkable what it takes is what we're
fearing this idea of a battery sorry
yeah I know I was also going to say if
you put your dot Square Bishop on the
wrong square if this is for the white
side right there's even Bishop takes H
like for example like this I I get in
trouble with yeah Bishop Rick takes E3
yeah and then also if you Castle
what I was thinking is obviously you
take the pawn yeah and one thing to kind
of Bear in mind is that you know White's
pieces are not very coordinated so apart
from the battery you also have these
ideas of going Bishop takes H3 at the
right time and maybe even rookie six and
lift it all up to the yeah yeah I must
admit my slow play really did did
uh get uh you should put the pawn on D4
you shouldn't keep the pawn on D3 you
really want to put the pawn on D4 and
try to clamp down on the structure like
that and could you kind of go a little
bit
yeah after D4 you know tried to run with
the King
no you can't
run with the King to the queen side
no running no running because also the
pawn on F2 is super weak yeah so you're
gonna okay very enterprising Pawn sack
Graphics I must say in my practice
funnily enough I've had this position as
white nobody played C6 against me but a
number of my opponents did play the move
B5
and at first I I thought this was a joke
a joke opening but then I began to
understand that if I do take the pawn
much like what Christian was saying the
compensation is actually quite fearsome
after D5 and I found myself playing a
little bit timidly the move D3 I did get
advantages but it is a strange move B5
and I must admit nobody played C6
against me
if I'm not mistaken has tried it uh just
last year for the first time let's see
C6
from
February 2022 that was kind of the stem
game that I remember and after that a
lot of very top level players started
playing uh this idea with C6 it's a very
good opening especially for Rapid chess
for classical okay there are some
pitfalls obviously you're giving up a
pawn and I do have a pretty secure
position if I manage to get that pawn to
D4 you have to be very fast and very
precise with your compensation but if
you know what you're doing and your
opponent doesn't which seems to be the
case right now for Irina and Alice well
Alice might actually have the upper hand
in this game with the black pieces and
by the way look she's taking a lot of
time for this move Knight to E2 I'm
telling you she's considering Bishop to
B5 it feels natural to try to get your
pieces out now you have to understand
the trade-off is just simply not worth
it you're letting go of your light
squares on the king side right and that
will be deadly in the long uh long run
right and because we're going to be
playing classical chess today no
elimination games no rapid games now is
a very very good chance for our audience
to join the conversation to stump our
commentary panel with your questions we
do have
um Talia and whiskey or Manning our
social media so this is how you can do
it ask the commentators you can simply
tweet using in the hashtag the American
Cup again send us your questions send us
your comments send us whatever you like
we also like selfies
all right and we will be ready for you
by the way arena is actually thinking a
lot about this moment we know from
Christian that Bishop B5 check would be
falling into a dangerous position but
she is considering it
considering that because I have you know
I just see one game on the database it
could be a disaster this you you know
but they did play at night H5
you know put your night on the edge of
the board well it has been played by two
International Masters really okay so the
reason why I would reject night H5 is
because I see it as a one-way ticket
only you're going to be playing Knight
F4 whether you like it or not whereas I
see the move 92 and I say well I'm
giving myself options she played Bishop
B5 guys oh I told you this is too
tempting pitiful it's very tempting to
get the bishop out with uh with a tempo
not good not good now Alice Lee is
officially and objectively in the
driver's seat standing well now Bishop
B5 Knight C6
Knight E2 Knight H5 you know 92 H3 this
well I mean uh Arena did this for a
reason let's see let's see if we can uh
G3 yeah to play G3
um let's see move on move Christian
what is the you you mentioned Queen F6
and queen F3 but exactly here how does
that happen with A6 A6 yeah hunting down
the light Square Edition
says Bishop let's take it you're gonna
take it okay okay I understand I
understand but now
you know where I'm going yeah right I am
not I'm not sick
I'm not going that way I'm going exit
stageless Bishop D7 Bishop David seven
yeah okay B6 could you kind of stop that
idea with Queen F6 as opposed to
or are you I might play it anyway
yeah yeah yeah very good uh
blimey
or yeah I don't know I mean I would
maybe I don't know uh
but let's say Bishop D7 just for a
second so again we're upon up you've got
all kinds of light Square control
um but I do have a clear idea Bishop B2
castles and okay let's play normally
Bishop D6 Bishop David six Bishop Castle
whoa castles
okay no you can jump
where can we jump Jeffy
can you live with your king
in the center
dangerous as long as you can it's not
the wrong Cloud I think the bong Cloud
as you go E3 and King E2 that's the bong
Cloud but how about
F2 so I'm kind of I've now I'm beginning
to Fear The Rush of the a pawn that's
why I want to live in the kit in the
center in the center as long as I can
and I do have a pawn Shield don't I with
the King on F2 how good or how bad is
this Christian it's about us it's it's
still it's battle but it's it's black
who's uh in the driver's seat
um F3 is not a great move F3 I will go
C5 and then I will yeah King F2 open up
this diagonal for my Bishop this is not
looking great yeah Rook to see it it's a
long-term initiative in fact yes press
compensation however you want to call it
um maybe this is something that is going
to be difficult for Alice to understand
if she hasn't studied this type of
positions uh extensively maybe she will
try to do something really really quick
right Knight C6 I don't I don't know how
you do that but perhaps you will be
um Tempted By by those ideas she has to
play it slow Bishop 6. get your king to
safety go short castle and just play a
long game in which you have the superior
control of the light squares because of
the light Scorpio you see and I wouldn't
have uh I wouldn't have felt that to be
the case my judge here's where my
judgment would probably uh mislead me I
look at the position I say yeah why it's
cramped and yeah black has the two
Bishops and I don't really have an
active plan but I falsely believe I'm
solid
like yeah it's good it's okay like
what's wrong and uh apparently Alice has
a very good position here
yes and uh thank you yes sir but uh
we'll we have a very special
announcement
my spidey sense is tingling okay happy
birthday take a look at this
oh here it comes
wow Christian you have aged terribly us
I know I know I know I mean
oh my goodness over the years the
transformation
my goodness great memories wow wow yeah
but that earlier photo of Christian you
can see a remarkable difference coaching
will do that they say I mean I've uh
yeah my hair has turned white I agree
it's just uh yeah you're going downhill
after 30 yeah that's the way it is okay
well thank you for that production team
that was very cute very cute but you
have the game of Hikaru in front of you
uh is this what it's come down to I was
trying to see what's happening in this
game and not that much has happened so
this is and I believe we all already saw
this in your analysis if I'm not
mistaken something along the lines of
take on B6 take on B6 Castle Queen to
the D7 you're not really in a hurry to
take on F3 because you can grab that
Bishop whenever you want Bishop to B2
this is the position once again the same
Trend seems to be repeating Hikaru is
playing very quickly in the opening
Wesley is thinking a lot in the opening
trying to pick and choose his uh choices
and this is what we have right now
Knight takes F3 was just played this has
been seen in a couple of games between
uh gullapup and medvegie and Petrov
versus void so not the elite level but
still this surely has been analyzed by
very strong players so Queen takes F3
but I would assume you're going to go
Castle you also have the option of
trying to force the queen trade with a
move Queen to G4 yes now is the question
is he going to sidestep that with the
move Queen to E3 or is he going to take
on G4 Queen to E3 has been seen in the
previous game the problem with this is
that you don't have a lot of forces as
white around the king side and I can try
to take advantage of that with the move
Knight to H5 Knight to H5 Knight to F4
is coming very quickly it does seem like
that gives black enough compensation for
the fact that there's a knight versus a
bishop that could potentially open up
after the move d4 so you have to be
careful for from a strategical point of
view as black you have to do things fast
by the way Castle was uh played Wesley's
choice not Queen to G4 Castle Queen to
E2 immediately responded by Hikaru still
following that game that I was
mentioning pop versus madwagi that one
was with Queen two E7 the engine is
saying Queen to G4 is like yeah I like
Queen G4 queen queen you know something
I feel that black has to do something
otherwise he's he's gonna drift
yeah I mean I was looking at this point
I was almost salivated
oh boy you saw sacrifices coming to F6
and that for that reason Queen G4 with
Queen G4 to kind of slow down that
Queenie F4 so for example qg4 F3 now you
would dream that the queen would would
Retreat that way now you've got
everything you want you're you're you're
in the driver's seat but Queen H5
temporarily slows you down and again I
feel that if you're getting into a
position that is closed versus a bishop
Midnight's okay then that the night will
somehow you know fish around and uh but
even this I have so much space right you
do if you do get the move F4 in the
position and you have to respond with
the move for example after F4 can I play
something like F5 I really just want to
exchange as many pieces as possible no
no F5 with black oh I bet you responded
four with F5 okay it's all about
exchanging and trading as many pieces as
possible okay it it's funny how uh the
coach is willing to make upon weaknesses
whereas I I I I I I feared maybe I just
want to simplify the position yes and
get rid of your Bishop you know but I
don't know isn't there some problems
with
exactly there might be there might be
what I'm looking is that the material is
quite limited and maybe this is going to
play in uh in my hands
I don't see an immediate exploitation
and you also have the A3 weakness right
you go Queen F3 I go C6 once again
material is very limited you do have one
weakness that you're attacking that's
the pawn on E5 but I also have the porno
yeah hey I have a passer aren't you in
the past are you impressed uh yeah that
looks rather balanced so F5 I think
you're right I think uh you you you do
have that opportunity as well can we try
to stop you from going F4 as much as
possible so Queen G4 F3 and now I go
Queen G5
oh excuse me uh just here uh yeah
keeping an eye over that uh Square not
only that but I'm also keeping uh the
extra score H5 for my knight so I have
ideas of Knight H5 Knight F4 or Knight
H5 F5 gotcha
all right uh I'm kind of influenced by
this move F through g g three uh sorry
can I ask the most critical question the
most critical yeah it is the most
critical question because I was uh if if
we were to rewind just a few more moves
when we get to the trade right here yeah
it's a pretty too cringy for what
happens if I just go you know what
two Brooks and a bishop dream Parry okay
two Rooks and a night not so good you
won a trade I want to trade and I take
that was a long-winded way of saying
that age three okay you're in my side
and now F4 okay and this is where I'm
saying that usually in a closed position
the Knight versus the bishop right the
Knight will find uh a circuit
really I'm looking at the position and
I'm saying to myself if if I could drop
the Knight where would I drop it I'd
probably drop it on the D4 Square not so
easy to get there but
okay I do have a root and if white tries
to accelerate the play immediately
immediately immediately I would just
kind of would D4 with D4 I realized that
I'm burning quite a few Bridges but I do
understand the five pound attack
I just wanted to put this one to the
test for everyone right
and uh well you've yeah you've taken
some responsibility with all your
problems yeah this one yes yes okay now
my knight is doing absolutely nothing
nothing
I
completely admit to that right
uh uh and you've got your king and I
build my king up I mean but you know
I've seen
these top players it's a you know
somehow they get these cramped positions
but they're solid right I mean you you
you're the normal way Jovi that you're
going to defeat uh your opponent in this
position is you're gonna win some
material and to win material you need a
Target right so in your mind as you look
at Black's position you say the only
thing you can really Target is the F6
pawn and I anticipate that you'll go G4
H4 and G5 of course and I'll make a
repair job and I will I will cut you off
at the past by playing H6 and starting
this type of position I mean
on a practical level I mean cortex G4
Queen taste G4 you have an edge I have
an edge so white has I would also agree
with that white black and solid but uh
you you're the one enjoying the space uh
unfortunately it's not going to be
enough these guys you know for for you
to defeat them you you you need more
rope you know it's going to be very hard
okay we'll keep that we'll keep our eye
on this a game uh shall we go over to
you and the Alice Lee game Christian
because that game
um nothing has happened nothing yet
severe but uh what strikes me as odd is
that Alice seems to be out of her book
so perhaps she did not anticipate this
move Bishop to B5 she saw the engine
eval she's understood that it's bad but
she didn't go deeper than that so maybe
she doesn't know exactly how to approach
this position whether to go H3 first
whether to go Bishop D6 or A6 these are
the things that Alice is considering
right now still thinking H3 to Maya is
at least makes the most sense just
create as many weaknesses and it's the
most logical right the bishop has left
the king side unprotected the light
squares should be exploited and this is
exactly how to do so with the move H3
that's the natural response in this
position let's wait and see what else is
going through right okay
hmm I'm still uh struggling uh
yeah you had it oh I did yeah
yeah I would say the next one next one
that was Alice and no that's it that's
perfect this is this is Hikaru and then
once you I hit it again yeah
and again and again
I'm in a loop I feel like I'm in The
Matrix and I can't get out
your companion is not great either
so I'm sorry
[Music]
we were perfect man perfectly matched
we're we're in deep trouble here okay uh
not that that's not what we wanted
actually uh and I'm having a real
trouble so
um white Christian if you could take it
away for a while and I'll try to get uh
production to save me save me so I might
have problems
let's take a look at what's happening in
this game by the way Queen to G4 as you
are mentioning has not been played Rook
28 makes a lot of sense it's all about
this idea of the move F4 and how do you
counteract that and I'm thinking that
Wesley thought about the position looked
at it a little bit and understood that
he has to put as many Defenders to the
pawn tie as many Defenders to the pawn
on E5 as possible this seems to be his
main idea but I'm looking at it and F4
makes a lot of sense how do you continue
after F4 F takes E5 is not a threat at
least not immediately so why not you're
getting attacked on the king side and
towards the center in general from a
logical perspective you have to find the
counter shot and this is exactly what
the engine as well is recommending with
this move B5 and I'm sure Wesley perhaps
is thinking along those same lines now
after this move B5 there's another idea
with Oracle E8 now for example let's say
you go King to H1 I have ideas of taking
taking and once the e-file opens e takes
F4 comes on the board and the e-file
opens not immediate because if you do
take I take on F6 and now the king is
very very exposed the blacking on G8 is
very exposed so you have to get ready
for that but once the e-file opens and
this Pawn from D3 has left the guard of
the Pawn on e4 then you're going to be
in trouble and it does seem like it's
the best way forward to go with Queen to
G4 at some point white will have to go
F5 sidestep this exchanges sidestep the
opening of the e-file but once F5 comes
on the board you also don't have a clear
way of opening up your Bishop on B2 so
that seems to be the general strategy
that we're seeing from Wesley so right
now
let's wait and see by the way uh Rook f8
is the novelty in the position I believe
Queen to G4 was played in the previous
no sorry Queen to E7 was played in the
previous game Rook f8 after a long thing
by Wesley so the first novelty in the
position and right now I'm expecting
Hikaru to uh take a pretty long thing
pause understand the differences in the
position and then make his move which
most likely is going to be F4 well again
after F4 B5 B5 isn't the C5 move you can
play C5 yeah yeah you can play C5 and
then I go Queen to E6 once again it's
all about trying to find my own counter
chances in the position right Queen E6
Queen to B3 Queen E6 take on e4 and then
uh D5 as well if you do take on E5 I
take back and it does seem like you have
created some weaknesses for yourself as
well not only that but setting the queen
on E6 allows my knight to jump back to
D7 which I think is very important for
example if you go Rook F5 finally my
knight gets to a defensive setup on D7 I
managed to close diagonal with the move
F6 then maybe reroute the Knight to G6
just play a very slow game slow
maneuvering game it doesn't seem like
you've accomplished your goals as why of
opening up the long diagonal with dire
consequences
yeah clever move by Wesley I would never
have dreamed of doing something like
that yeah he's good yeah yeah I mean
it's it's strange because I was really
trying to stop the move therefore and
it's sort of like he's saying I embrace
it go ahead play F4 the half open f file
is not fearsome
I can just handle I'll I'll just I'll
just handle that and that is really
confounding because they thought you
know like F4 B5 C5 Queen E6 I thought
okay now the you know a moment ago I was
trying to double on the a file and now
it sort of like isn't white going to be
the one dictating terms on the king side
he's saying 97 and
yeah shut it down I have an interesting
question though because F4 is on tap for
the other at the minute so right what
does have the opportunity now to make an
improvement move like Rook ae1 okay so
it's coming
it's coming F4 but uh yeah I'm gonna do
it when I'm a bit more able to defend E4
right and uh okay if I just follow the
same prescription that Christian laid
down for me
no no F4 F4 Queen
yeah I was wondering about that maybe I
can take this one yes
I'm not sure suddenly
um
are you ever going to take my it going
to give me your an exchange
you're not going to yeah I was thinking
you're a nice person no I'm not a nice
person I'm quite mean I can't taste porn
I go there okay just as chess chess is
chess and here well I do have an
Intermezzo so Rook takes F6 immediately
but even then you know you've got porn
takes porn so if I don't want to roll
the dice not quite yes yeah and then
this is where I quickly and then go to
that whole uh plan of Christian move the
Knight and shut the bishop out which is
quite an effective plan okay so if I if
I go for it and I'm like you know what
are you feeling lucky are you feeling
lucky yes okay I'll take this one are
you gonna take that one you're right
you don't just Checkmate me no not not
so easy that's so easy not on my
birthday too exactly but also there's no
peace around the black king I mean I
feel like you're giving me presents here
at system exchange okay and uh Christian
once again how are the ladies doing uh
uh let's jump to that not much once
again nothing has happened
um Asics has not been played H3 has not
been played at least still is still
thinking and yeah once again we
understand that she's so probably the
most Bishop to B5 uh she saw that the
engine is saying that it's not a great
move and she probably decided not to
analyze it in depth and that could cost
her right now well for me it's I I just
don't understand how Alice cannot
play the move H for H3 it's sort of like
she rushed the H Pawn up the board with
a gamer gain of tempo the light Square
Bishop is move is moved White's light
squared Bishop is moved the move H3 is
howling the B plays you would be
surprised so really yeah there's a
couple of games and in both of them very
strong players who are with the black PC
Sam Sevin played it in March of 2022 and
then Jordan van Forest followed it up in
May 2022 and
um he played a different move not H3 Sam
Savion played the move H3 first
Jordan van Forest played the move A6 in
this position started off with A6 and
allowed this idea of taking on C6 and
stop the weakening of the light squares
with the move H3 right so and Jordan was
a promising Talent
[Laughter]
just about 2700 where did it go wrong
you didn't he didn't play H3 Sam Sam did
play H3 and then he followed it up with
A6 so H3 G3 A6 yes that was the game
right H3 G3 A6 take on C6 and I'm
looking it's not easy I I'm looking at
some lines Queen to A4 was actually
played by Ilya nishnik a Saint Louis
local as well Queen to F6
and queen to F4 and
what is the most unlikely
square that you would put the queen in
this position
the most unlikely unlikely yes
at first glance Queen A5
that would be unlikely I wouldn't go to
E6 just because and I wouldn't go to
East I I yeah I would be going to G6 and
I'd be thinking about but now I'm like
looking at Queen E7 and thinking it's
not bad actually Queen E6 is actually
the best move allowing Knight to D4
which makes not a lot of sense to me
Knight to D4 and then Queen to G6 back
and saying that that Knight on D4 is
actually going to be a Target because
I'm going to go Bishop to D6 follow it
up with C5 and I'm going to gain some uh
something time yeah with uh by hitting
the Knight on D4 so very strange play I
have to say not easy from a practical
and a human's perspective she played
Bishop D6
no H3 no H3 no A6 D6 okay is that a
novelty it's a novelty yes D6 is a
novelty and by the way not a great
novelty it seems like
but
I don't know if you would play this move
short Castle is the best movie in the
position no no no no no no no
you would not play that I would not be
reaching you will not be touching that
no yeah
um I would be thinking how can I
uh Preserve my light squared Bishop uh
I'm almost tempted by the move Knight D4
here 94 okay just so that in case you
did Play Bishop D7 and I'm thinking you
know I I understand this compensation no
question
but at least
can I go Queen G5 I'm just going to ask
that question because it's legal I'm not
I'm not walking
no I think yeah wait I don't need a
birthday suit to understand uh I'm being
done here I mean oops uh so yeah I'd
have to play a little bit of an ugly
move liking of one great compensation
that's not looking good right no but at
least I'm preserving the light Square
Bishops I was like uh bishoped to D
excuse me Bishop to D6 novelty by Alice
and well castles is the best move you're
saying there's no kill not yet yes so
for example if you go G3 I go oh H3 I go
G3 and if you try to go Queen F6 and get
to F3 I already have Castle on the board
and I can play F3
right
yeah
oh here we go now Rex is aged well he
hasn't changed
one bit
oh you know what I like about these
pictures you're always smiling and that
is that is you yes that's me yeah
okay that's what I have to say you don't
look at day older than 62 and a half
right right that half is very important
in America is that and you know the
crazy part is I don't feel a day older
than 62 either
just feeling like I did yesterday in
fact I was having a lot of fun yesterday
uh during all of these uh Blitz at uh
Rapids castles
okay that is quite the challenge and
maybe maybe Arena will play it one of
the reasons I do actually like the move
castles is I suddenly realize that if I
play F4 I'm actually cutting out your
Bishop on the dark squares and maybe on
a good day I can play like Ben Larson B3
F4 Bishop V2 and get my own long
diagonal the first movie that I will be
playing here usually A6 A6
am I obliged to take it well well you
could I mean I you could go back I guess
I guess
I'm not enthusiastic I mean I was asking
with like tell me yes
it's a legal move right and if I do take
it you you your follow-up let's let's
put it that way was let's no F3 is okay
I'll I'll bite okay
and then I guess a A3 has h3.com at some
point oh Queen F6 in this uh Queen F6 I
may have set myself up for
no I got Knight F4 so I'm still I'm
still by the way
wow Arena really uh bravely yeah uh
quite quick picking up the gauntlet
there with the move castles
sorry is why it's a blast the night
well I'm gonna have to go to my go-to
Guru on this one uh uh Christian
definitely not the blight no no
definitely not obliged you can play
bishop or perhaps
but
I would take on C6 right
I don't know I just feel like that gives
me another tempo
that could help my defense so I would
probably take on C6
take on C6 right take on C6 take on C6
should I be fighting for some light
squares with moves like Queen C2 or
should I just
be playing uh moves like H3 and or F3 uh
Christian I don't know you tell me yes
sir analyze I'm not the one who got
myself I did this pickle
I don't like my king being under a
duress of you know Queen G5 and H3 and
Bishop H3
um very intriguing position I have to
say it is very interesting but somehow I
I feel that there's a danger that Alice
could run out of steam yes absolutely
and then she's gonna Rue the day because
she's got no safe place for the king to
run to as well right so so for example a
move like Queen C2 if you do play let's
just play and you do end up going here
you kind of start to say well what you
doing
yeah I mean F4 Knight to D4
White's got some dark Square control
that's that that that's you have to take
seriously uh it's not easy to suggest an
attacking plan for Alice Alice having
sacrificed upon earlier in the game
let's go back to
um the open section for a second and we
do have moves or maybe not that might be
our analysis actually
what happened in the game F4 was played
by Hikaru
no Preparatory move like your rookie E1
just let's go for it and after B5 we're
up to Karu is now thinking
um what is the computer valuation as say
about this exact moment after 16 moves
very very slight pull for uh for white
0.3 perhaps if you leave the computer to
think for a long time 0.1 or maybe even
zeros and this is not a very strong
engine so yeah I mean white doesn't seem
to have much B5 is a very timely break
on the queen side if we were playing
name that opening name that opening so I
gave you this middle game position and I
said which opening
did this position come from would you
say a Joko piano or would you say in
English
because it has both features right I
would say English the simple because
there's no light squared Bishops on the
board and I can't think of a single well
Joker piano they play Bishop E6
they trade the Bishops on B on E6 The
Rook takes it comes yeah and then the
Rook goes back C5 on the board and would
you say it was from a Joko piano or
would you like Jovi with the knowledge
she has
today's game also say English
um
yeah that's uh that's a tough question I
would probably say English as well okay
yeah I mean actually and I've always
thought of that as as a as a Trivial
Pursuit like game chess trivia right
you've got this chess trivia and I give
you a whole series of openings here oh
that's easy that's a queen's gamma do oh
that's easy that's a king's India they
give you this one go whoa whoa wait a
minute there's a couple of uh
transpositions here C5 on the board so
they followed your advice so well uh
Queen E6 Queen E6 is the money move this
is the defensive money move the
continuation of the advice just to just
to get out of the way uh for the night
by the way the move F4 F5 doesn't
disturb you in the least probably
because the queen seems perfectly okay
on B3 unless it's not wait a minute
did I put no but maybe you just go back
to E7 yeah now that you achieved your
goal of closing up the diagonal there's
no more tension on E5 right I can just
go back
this feels like an overreach of sorts
unless you're going to go G4 G5 and that
has consequence uh exactly your Center
it's not very stable so I would never do
that right
and uh all right well tell us uh tell us
about our friends at Q Boutique what are
they offering us today something very
lovely lovely here is one of the
favorite St Louis chess club souvenirs
an athletic style Polo available in a
variety of colors and in both men's and
women's sizing up your game with one of
these attractive polos and it's
available now exclusively at
qbtakestl.com you can see the colors
there you had me at athletic that's my
size
not straight not slim athletic athletic
that's a good size nice and we're going
to take a short break but uh in the
meantime we did ask the players what did
they think about the state of Chess in
America
thank you
there's a lot of rising talent in the
United States how do you see the future
of American jobs yeah things are going
great for American chess I mean I
definitely think the St Louis chess club
has contributed a lot to that uh since
it opens its doors in 2008 has provided
so many opportunities good tournaments
for young players lots of support United
States the best country in the world to
be a chess professional right now so we
have very strong up-and-coming players I
see it at the like chess camps that I'm
teaching that it's becoming really
crowded and we can see like how many
talents are going to come out of that so
I think maybe in 10 15 years it's going
to be even more crowded than it's now
every generation of American players has
had so much more opportunity than the
one that came before it I know that I
had so much more than all the people who
mentored me and the ones coming after me
have so much more than I did and the
ones coming out for them will have so
much more further and you know the
United States has produced some pretty
strong players you know we've got Ray
Robson and myself and Icarus and three
guys over 2700 that you know the US has
produced from day one and uh and yeah I
think that we have for a bright future
ahead with solver up and coming
youngsters I think um it's it's really
great to see what has happened with
chess here in St Louis the opportunities
for the junior players I think right now
at least as we look at this event in the
women's field specifically there's Alice
Lee who's 14 years old and certainly
she's a very bright future ahead of her
just in general for the players who are
younger the players who haven't had
these opportunities to compete against
the best players it's really something
special for them and I think it's really
good in terms of furthering American
Trust I think American chess has been
growing the last decade a lot I keep
hearing from players around my age
complaining how at the open tournaments
there are so many kids and they're also
underrated and they all play so well but
of course for the future it's great the
US has a strong team and for the last
couple of years I think they're
supporting especially the Young
Generation with a lot of tournaments in
Saint Louis
and I think we're going to see a lot of
Juniors to shine in the world
competition so yeah they have bright
future in my opinion well I think the
Young Generation they're insanely strong
and they're working hard they're playing
a lot of tournaments this is really
great that we have these tournaments
where the very top players get to
interact with up-and-coming players we
have
um and for women's chess we also have
some very players like obviously who's
playing here she's I think she's still
only 13 she's 23.60. for me personally
that I'm a newcomer to American chess
it's a great joy to see
many talented kids you know and
they're up and coming
see
Mishra and also Alice Lee
they're extremely talented and they're
very very young so I think the future is
bright we could probably have like three
really strong Olympia teams if we were
allowed to send three teams in the
future yeah I think it's great obviously
I think the chess club has definitely a
part to do with that just incentivizes
young players to really think that there
is a path in professional pursuing
professional chess yeah I think there's
a long way
for us to go there's a lot of potential
it's going really well there's a lot of
young players you mentioned Alice Lee
today I played on a team with her in
online chess event for the St Louis
archbishops and she beat a 2700 rated
player so she's she's done that before I
mean she beat another like super Grand
Master very recently so I think we'll
see a lot of like 2600 plus players from
that group 2600 maybe some 2700 plus
players as well and maybe some future
top players as well uh I think
definitely
um like my peers and the people outside
the older are definitely like really
strong I think that American chess is
like um really bright I know that chess
itself has become super popular lately
and for me to see like a lot of my
classmates who wouldn't normally be
playing chess uh start playing chess
um in class for in free time I feel like
that indicates that because of the
popularity of American chess is growing
more people will start to play another
result we would definitely see a lot of
new strong players in the Next
Generation overall like us chess uh St
Louis chess club is doing a great up in
like advertising the how like chess can
be like really great uh super fun to
play and overall yeah I think that
um American chess definitely has a
really bright future
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
and we are back and it's the Grand Final
where we're gonna see winners being
determined in the next few days yes the
title is at stake I know yes I can't
believe it because I thought it was like
yesterday yeah when you came on and you
told me day eight I said my goodness
we've been having too much fun uh
calling the action for those of you are
joining us late out of the 81 games
played so far in the tournament 44 have
been decisive and over 50 I'm used to
the sinkfield Cup scores you know 25
decisive so we have sure had our full uh
share of ethereals and Spills I'm
looking at the game of Alice Lee and
Alice did a few things that I felt were
a little bit slow including her failure
to play the move h4h3 we have this
position on the board and just as we
were returning from break I was thinking
to myself okay but
isn't Alice inviting the move Knight C3
the idea of course is I want to capture
the pawn that's clear but also much more
importantly I would love to be able to
capture this bishop and I feel like I
would really be neutralizing what was
going on and as we were coming up break
we were just having this little
discussion castles I understand this was
really uh maybe asking too much out of
the position I didn't want to take and
allow you you were ready because the
queen E5 as well yeah check and uh you
will win back the bishop win win back
the piece pardon me while
um messing up my king but I did see the
move d4 and I thought okay
um Arena might be in business of sorts
here right I mean but if you just throw
caution to the wind and just go
I don't care about this D4 Pawn you
don't because
because you know you're just going to go
age through age three difficult age
three difficult to come up with a move
actually right
um
somehow
I I I I I I
I I right
and nothing is
we're gonna have to ask our main go-to
coach
uh here uh we're thinking Knight C3 as
some pertinent questions not good not
good no Knight C3 not good yet you have
to go D4 first yes stop the ideas of
potentially striking uh in the center
for black with the move d4 by cementing
the structure as is with the move d4
we rejected not immediately I don't have
to play it immediately no no no no I
don't think this works no it doesn't I
don't think this is of course but it's
not about that it's not about any sort
of like fancy ideas no it's about just
putting the kibosh on the development of
that Pawn C1 because after I get
the pawn on D4 then I can go Queen E5
take on D6 now it's more difficult to
get that Bishop out of play right and I
have a lot of time to do things like
Castle potentially long and then I will
uh inflict a lot of damage to your
position don't do this just play the
move d4 they don't these Jedi Mind
Tricks don't work on me G C3 I mean The
Bishop's coming now I tricked you unless
I mess unless I'm missing something
Queen side Castle let's go whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
takes porn so how do you do it takes
takes and now
frequency
okay I'm ready for you I see it I see it
I'm gonna put my RO I've got the two
Bishops I will go H3 first though uh at
this particular moment in time so just
before once you go B3 I go H3 myself
right okay you provoked me and now if
you go G3 I take on E3 first okay you
you got it you take back yeah now I go
Queen E5
but am I trying to equalize I mean black
is trying to equalize right now black is
trying yeah yeah I mean it's sort of
easy to equalize
that I
I mean I can equalize on them on the
move you made it sound like my Bishop on
C1 was no no no no no trouble no no but
after D4 which was played now the engine
and perhaps Irena understands this as
well because she played it so fast uh
White is much better right now ah like
okay black doesn't have any ways to
equalize black doesn't have that much
going on in the position
we intuitive properly that in fact Alice
has let her initiatives should that end
yes the combination of the moves D4
Knight C3 is bringing Arena the
advantage exactly okay a one point
Advantage this is the largest advantage
that Irena has had in this game up to
this point still not easy still some
compensation left that King is a little
bit weak with that threatening thorn in
the position that pawn on age four
potentially coming to H3 but at the same
time a pawn is upon the structure is
very healthy for white I have Knight C3
maybe even E4 at the right moment you
have to be careful about those type of
things right and in the meantime sure
find find the the compensation find the
PATH forward to get to my king how do
you do that as black it's not clear at
all exactly not easy at all I mean nope
I I don't see anything because
everything can be powered and there's no
entry points for the big pieces no entry
points very good point Jovi yeah I mean
the moment you play G5 and G4 presumably
when you're a castle that can bypass you
with it exactly and every time you go
Bishop C7 Queen D6 well white just goes
well hello there I'm going to block that
one exactly well F4 exactly and that's
all you got and h3s are always going to
be blocked with G3 it's a very very
difficult position suddenly for Alice to
maintain and we have to remind ourselves
this is the Grand Final how did the
other six players I was gonna do in the
tournament and let's take a look at them
as we've already told you about the
money prizes right here we go and here
we have Katarina nemsava she was
relegated in the first round by a game
took in Genova and eliminated by Tata
abrahamian in the first round of the
elimination bracket
and then we have Anna satonsky she's
been a former US champion she was
relegated to the elimination bracket by
Naji paikitsa and eliminated by a
two-star percussion in the first round
of the elimination bracket also sadly
she lost her
baggage on route
but not a good yeah
not a good outing and uh to have
abrahamian relegated in the first round
by Arena crash eliminated by najibank is
in the second round of the elimination
and then we have a tusha percussion and
she was relegated by Alice Lee and
eliminated in the second round by
begging talking to Nova by the way a big
shout out and a welcome to a Tusa this
was her first time in St Louis she said
she had a marvelous time and uh here was
Christian's pick and also Christian
Student So Christine was very loyal she
was relegated in the second round of the
championship bracket by Arena eliminated
by najibitis in the second round of
Elimination Brackets
and talk about excitement she brought it
into this uh American company yes sir
she was relegated in the second round by
Alice and eliminated by the competition
by Alice again in the fourth round of
the elimination bracket so whoa it's
incredible I actually this type of
tournament you know you were one of
eight and now there's two women
remaining we'll tell you about the
Champions uh in the open section later
in the meantime uh again I'm looking at
the position with Alice after this move
D2 D4 and both
um Jovi and I
are at a loss to make a suggestion for
Alice like what is she supposed to do
right here because we're looking at the
position and we're saying
the happy moves the easy moves belong
all to White yeah an arena exactly she
ran out of steam in the position with
black pieces she should probably try to
create something as you guys were
intending via the B8 H2 diagonal with
Bishop C7 Queen to D6 but even so after
I played the move F4 how do you once
again continue where is the entry points
you have to hide your king I mean the
King on E8 despite the fact that sure
it's been the white king that's getting
viciously attacked and you have to find
the defense uh the black king on E8 is
not safe once I played the move E4 later
on in the future also you have to find a
way to defend that pawn on D5 so how do
you do that probably with long Castle it
makes a lot of sense right right you
don't want to go short Castle because if
you do go short Castle Queen to H5 comes
on the board now you have a newly
created weakness the pawn on H4 I'm
going to Target that I'm going to Target
The Pawn on D5 as well not looking good
yeah but if you go long Castle Quinto F3
yeah how do you continue where is your
attack who's attacking who exactly I
mean this is the problem so you have to
defend D5 because I at first I was
thinking oh half an hour puff and I'll
blow your house down with Chief with G5
yeah D5 is D5 yeah yeah and exactly yeah
so A6 inviting Bishop takes C6 I assume
not probably not yes and then
trying to trick you
don't play F5 no but now I can just
simply develop Bishop D2 and then put a
rook on C1 yeah I'm hoping hoping hoping
and that's probably what you have to do
yes right that's most likely your best
chance but once again it's not going to
be easy to prove that you have a path
forward I can even try to go ideas of
Knight to E2 perhaps well now is the
time isn't it now the bishop has moved
to E6 just to kind of consolidate oh
yeah I like your knight YouTube by the
way just to defend it I was actually
thinking Bishop takes Knight and for the
records he won but yeah you know what
let's think of of bigger things okay
let's try to be a bit more aggressive
with white instead of Knight to E2
yeah let's continue and play Rook C1 and
let's try to find some sort of counter
shot on the C file uh what did we do
Bishop A6
Bishops
instead of uh instead of night
you wanted to play which one let's go
Rook C1 okay C1 yeah okay well and then
let's have some fun but then you've got
Bishop takes night right either that or
maybe even just take the pawn back
it was my dream here I think I feel like
whenever I do get this in I'm creating
enough chaos so I feel like it's about
three years old game kind of thing yeah
so
but if you take it then I've got Knight
D4 and do I have something in return so
Queen F2 let's say
well I have enough compensation
well I mean you just let me win my Pawn
back which was very generous
it is my birthday it is your birthday
I'm trying to be nice
what not to E4 whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
it might not work but Pawn takes and
then the bishop comes out to a oh Bishop
A5 no no no no no no no no I I'm I'm
warming up to it yeah yeah why not let's
try it out wow
I like it okay that came out of the blue
that's what I'm saying we have to maybe
be a bit more aggressive okay
wow interesting position definitely you
can take the safer out out with Knight
E2 right that's right that's easy and I
don't think you want to play G4 because
then I go Queen F2 and you still don't
have a clear way of opening up and once
you don't have any tension left on that
pawn on F4 that Bishop on C7 and Queen
on D6 battery is kind of useless right
right I feel like I I should probably
evaluate the C file and uh okay it is by
the way
you know when you see this type of a
position
where you go Bishop C7
Knight C3 Queen D6 your first thought is
great on creating a battery but then
when you see the move F4 shutting
yourself down you stop thinking that
that you should play like this because
you see your opponent just slammed the
door shut and you go no no no that can't
be good for me you you almost have to
continue from here the problem I think
that Alice is facing right here right
now
the Alternatives what are they if not
Bishop C7 and if not Queen D6 defending
the D5 Pawn I really hate anything that
would involve 97 like if I go castles
Knight C3 I really think that white is
so happy to be able to trade these
Bishops go Queen D3 it's like it feels
like it's play on one goal suddenly and
uh the advantage has grown tremendously
so it feels like Bishop C7 uh due to
lack of Alternatives Christian how about
the open section what's happening there
well it seems like Rook ac1 was played
after the move Queen to E6 which was
found by Wesley the best move in the
position with the idea of bringing back
the Knight to D7 and defend this complex
in the center of the board and the C6
was the move we expect taking on D6 and
now not taking back obviously because if
you take back I take only a5n you're
pretty much busted in the position but
rather just a simple move Knight to D7
I'm going to defend protect over protect
the we know you like names of each and
all his palsyaser over protect this Pawn
on E5 and then later on take on D6 with
the queen seems to be just fine for
black seems to be like there's no Rook
to C5 because of this Knight on D7 I
mean you can try it if you want give up
the exchange like this but I don't think
this is going to be very pleasant could
you try to go for like
D4 here yeah maximum tension can I take
sounds like a great movie like max power
but if you the problem is if you go E5 I
think I have Queen takes D6 right
exactly
wow enough no but I know even that
position actually I had that position in
my mind but um I was good and perhaps I
would take on F4 it seems to be the
better one ah yeah because I had the
position with it takes on D4 yeah and
then I was thinking Rook the root can
come and Corral and then I thought that
this wasn't necessarily that yeah easy
for black yeah yeah you're right it's
not that easy but I take on F4 this is
the better option and if you go E5 now I
take on D6 right and now if you take on
B5 I can just simply take on D4 and
that's that's why I take on F4 first
because I take with the check then I
pick up the queen restored material
balance and it's uh in fact black who is
slightly better because I have more
weaknesses to play against the pawn on
E5 and the pawn on A3 as well so a very
intriguing position but I have to say
both players right now are playing a
very very good shots by the way there's
a nice little trick from the current
position after the move C7 C6 yes and
that is to take on D6 a 97 take on E5
uh-huh 1965 D4 oh nice you know it looks
like and E5 isn't that so sweet I I I've
got an extra Pawn but this Knight takes
d6s
that's that's the cold shower yeah the
like Knight takes D6 and you're worse
now you're risking to be worse because
the dark squared Bishop all all the
pawns are on dark squares I have the
nice Outpost for the queen on D5 right
Outpost for the Knight on C4 attacking
your weakness in the position on A3 you
don't want to see this with the white
pieces in hikaru's shoes all right and
uh let's take a look at all the
finishers in the open section we've got
six players who got eliminated we did
um about the excitement oh Sam savian he
was eliminated from the championship
bracket by Hikaru Nakamura and
eliminated from the competition by Levon
aronian quite a very exciting match and
then we have
Ray Robson who was relegated in the
first round by Fabiano carawana big name
eliminated by Sam Shanklin Ray might
have played yeah Ray might have played
the game of the tournament however in
that elimination game against Sam
Shanklin he won a beautiful beautiful m
game which he played so patiently but
unfortunately Sam came back Sam came
back and here we see Sam shankland who
was relegated in the second round by
lenia Dominguez at eliminative on the
competition by Wesley so our finalists
our finalist and we also have Fabiana
caruana who was American Cup champion
2022 and he was relegated in the second
round by Wesley so in Sutton epic match
that Lavon wow seven seven out of seven
games were decisive what a Armageddon we
saw and there we saw lenia Dominguez he
was relegated in the second round by
Hikaru Nakamura and eliminated by Lavon
aronian yesterday it's the third round
of Elimination Brackets and then finally
navon aronian well he lost in the first
round to linear Dominguez got his
revenge he's got his revenge I mean
limit but he was unfortunately
eliminated by Wesley so in the fourth
round of the elimination bracket that
was yesterday the other one was day
before yesterday they were all kind of
gone so quickly but Lavon the excitement
he brought the games the creativity the
content it was all great again
I had to go to Armageddon I feel like a
story could be even a movie it could be
told about that yeah for for me purpley
aside that no exaggeration to say one of
the greatest matches I've ever called it
was just that much fun and to see it
unfold and to take it all the way to
Armageddon as the players did well
that's the way you had to eliminate uh
Fabi the defending champion because he's
tough to eliminate I remember that Bobby
won the championship with one second on
his clock should arena do the same thing
she had one secondary on her Co-op
against Alice Lee right yeah
[Music]
he pointed out to her and she was like
no but I started off in more time and
the Christian was like no you made your
move with one second and you hit the
clock with like Point whatever right
attraction less than half a second yeah
a fraction
and we do have some tweets as uh we get
our audience involved with ask the
commentators Jovi take it away this one
is from okay mint snacks
everyone is asking us how effective do
you think Fisher random is in
strengthening your calculation skills
first of all I love Fisher random from
the simple perspective of forget about
opening preparation right and it it now
when I play Fisher random I'm thinking
it's more like
strategic yes positional and games your
test you're testing all of the skills
because in Fisher random you've shuffled
the pieces along the back ranks so
you're getting new positions each time
you can't rely upon your opening
preparation to get you into that middle
game so I really feel like it's a game
where you know you fall back on your
skills calculation is one of those very
important skills absolutely I agree and
we see Wesley was so good at this
because you know he knows instinctively
how to maneuver the pieces how to
advance with the pawns I mean it's very
difficult to play chess 960 official
random when your queen is like lodged
there
yeah yeah I don't know how I'm gonna get
out and your king is somewhere where it
shouldn't be but I mean it's a great
game and I remember the great Arthur
yusubov saying that when he trained on a
Fisher random he he thought it was like
the equivalent of playing chest but with
a heavy backpack right you got to get
your pieces into position jumping
Christian uh what's your what's your
thoughts about Fisher random
calculations yeah so the way I see it it
doesn't help your calculation that much
because the patterns when you compare it
when you train for chess right because
the patterns are not necessarily the
same what it does help for sure is your
creativity and your creativity can be
used in chess in the opening in the
middle game in the end game anywhere so
I think this is the main factor uh and
the main attribute that improves when
you practice chess 960 not necessarily
your calculation but you know who knows
maybe you guys are right yeah and of
course we will have our 9lx Fisher
random returning here to St Louis that I
think is going to be somewhere in
September I don't have the calendar we
lost you yeah
okay what about another tweet we have
this one also uh
what do you find most challenging about
over the ball tournaments against online
play and wishing you a happy birthday
thank you for that well absolutely over
the board tournaments for me
um I have to say are completely
different because we're we're sitting
here physically together I'm looking at
my opponent I can see they're visibly
nervous or not it's like darn it he's
why isn't he nervous I'm nervous I got
this position over the board uh pardon
me online event I don't even see my
opponent
all I see is the screen so I think
they're just two completely different uh
types of Chess and for me IO was always
raised with over the board chess today
the online tournaments are becoming so
rich I mean the prize money is so great
that I understand that the players today
have to take online tournaments
extremely seriously yeah no I I agree
you know I was raised with either the
ball tournaments but you know in after
the pandemic kind of struck I started to
kind of develop a little bit more of an
interest in online tournaments and I I
find them equally fascinating I think in
order for it to be fair I think that
they should have shorter time controls
they're equally rich in excitement and
also strategy but there is something
special about sitting across from your
opponents and feeling all the pressure
feeling all the emotions eyeballing your
opponent and saying you know what are
you going to do against this right
I can tell you the time scrambles that
you get on over the board are way more
exciting than the one because the online
is just the speed of the mouse you know
you see these guys and they're making
second I'm taking sorry making moves
with like a second if that yeah it's
just unbelievable jump in as a coach you
know what it's like to be over the board
as well as online I think you guys uh
yeah quite understood quite well and
explained it very very well it's about
the psychology versus mechanics in over
the board chess is the psychology you
get to see your opponent you get to
understand his feelings very personally
right when you play online chess it's
all about and it's very much about the
mechanics the mechanics of you are
taking the mouse in the right position
and things of that nature and if you're
not ready and if you haven't practiced
that you're at a huge disadvantage and
then you have the kids that start
playing with Blitz online or bullet
online since there are like five years
of age and then by the time they're 15
they can make 50 moves in three seconds
you know and of course you're not going
to be able to do that if you haven't
practiced it in your early years so I
think uh definitely the new generation
has a significant Advantage when it
comes to online chess what do you guys
think about that hmm I I I agree uh
those mouth skills and I've watched
hyper bullet not just you know uh one
minute chess but 30 second chass said
I've watched Dania nordiski playing uh
hyper bullet and I think to myself you
know if you weren't born with a mouse in
your hand there's no way you could
imitate what he does in uh 15 seconds
and by the way for those who are joining
us late uh shame on you first of all but
welcome nonetheless we have two uh Grand
finals matches underway uh Jovi and uh
you and I both predicted
in the women's section it is the highest
ranked seed Arena crash facing off
against number two the 13 year old Alice
Lee
and these matches will probably most
likely conclude tomorrow and in the open
section we have again the highest top
rated person number five in the world
Hikaru Nakamura facing off against
Wesley so if you know who is such a
juggernaut when it comes to these types
of Chess and I think he's like number
eight
in the world
very good and yeah the games are
underway a little bit surprised by the
move Bishop to D2 come on it's a
development why is that so surprising
well because Knight C3 looked
so much more tempting I wanted to say
for arena this night on C3 pressuring
this Pawn on D5 immediately certainly
caught our eye Bishop D2 is fine there's
nothing wrong with Bishop T2 but
you know when you get this opportunity
to hit
while the opportunity is there uh I I
think you need to take advantage Knight
C3 was simply a stronger move Bishop D2
basically says to Alice okay your turn
Alice will probably say say something to
the effect that my king doesn't belong
on the open C file let me tackle it for
the moment with the move like King A8
possibly even A7 A6 since uh one of the
other the other things I did like about
Knight C3 is that in this case if you
did play A7 A6 sometimes
again playing the bishop back I really
really wanted to preserve that bishop
and ideas of f4 Bishop F3 uh we think
arena is much better with the move
Bishop D2 did she lose not so much no
Advantage not not so much no not so much
the ideas are pretty much the same uh
and it's not like you have to defend uh
precisely against some sort of a
checkmating attack on the king side the
attack on the king side is not as fast
as you thought it would be at the
beginning of the game right you still
have to go Bishop C7 Queen to D6 then G5
and I have plenty of time to set up my
defense in that case now what I'm
thinking that Irina is hinting at by
delaying this move Knight to C3 is
exactly that we've seen it in a lot of
instances I was retreating my knight
back from C3 to E2 to defend that square
F4 I think this is what arena is trying
to do leave the Knight on E2 and get
ready to meet Queen to D6 with the move
F4 and then G5 I have my knight on E2
the pillar of Defense in the position
defending that pawn on F4 I think this
is what she's looking at in the meantime
another thing and another idea that we
were trying to implement in our
variations was this attack this counter
shot on the C file right and this is
what she seems to be focusing on Bishop
to D2 followed by Rook to C1 I think she
has some clear intentions right now
against the King on C8 so
look I'm looking at the position I
understand how Alice is feeling right
now she's a pawn down she sacrificed
upon she was dreaming about this
incredible compensation on the light
squares she doesn't even have the light
Square Bishop advantage that Bishop is
still on B5 right and you're not going
to force me to give it away with A6
anymore whenever I go AC whenever you go
A6 I go by four and I'm going to
be fine in the position so you start
getting desperate when you don't see
where your compensation lies in the
position and I'm afraid this is what
Alice is feeling right now well Alice
maybe heard about that desperation
because it wasn't the move that she
could have played earlier but she's
looking at something active she she did
play the move Bishop C7 as we had
anticipated a move or two ago she's
ready to play her battery and this is
where uh Christian was actually I what
he was saying uh
Arenas thinking that
black is going to attack the F4 Square
the Knight of E2 stands ready at the
guard and so why move the knight in when
you go Queen D6 that is what Arenas
probably thinking he's right I think
he's right as well and I was going to
say well irina's like main joke is
actually as a coach and as a coach we
often say you know if your king is under
Fire they don't get bold and like move
all your pieces onto the other side
don't be like yes there's something
around your king keep the guard yeah
keep your guard up at all times defend
yourself at all times
it's nice to have that that night there
the night is after all king's best
friend and you can get on with ideas of
going either A3 and uh well definitely
everything to play for and in the
meantime we also get to have a get to
see a couple more tweets okay challenge
let's go we're ready for the challenge
of our
tiger three on Twitch asks how does yasa
plan on celebrating his birthday oh
that's easy we're gonna go out and have
dinner tonight uh everybody in the
Central West End who lives in St Louis
is invited yay no not quite not quite no
in this particular case I think uh we're
gonna we're gonna go with the Antiques
the best antiques are old friends and
we're going to invite a lot of friends
to dinner tonight I think that's that's
the plan but thank you for the question
yeah another tweet we're ready yeah we
got challenges today and uh it's from M
until Dallas next says speaking of name
that opening I would love to hear yasu's
thoughts on the sarawan attack
yes I played it in the Phillips and Drew
tournament in London I defeated Nigel
short with it but I must say
unfortunately in my particular case I
borrowed the idea completely from one of
Victor's pupils a legend in the
Northwest Victor's pupils would play D4
Knight F6 C4 E6 Bishop G5 and he had
some really wonderful ideas and we
played a lot of Blitz together when I
was really really young and uh he got me
a few times and I said right if I could
fall for it somebody else will as well
so even though it does bear my name and
because I played it in the Grand Master
circles and Victor's didn't play in the
Grand Master circles but he deserves all
the credit Victor's pupils oh that's his
name yes Victor I
a legend in Northwest chess a big shout
out to Victors I think he's now
well he could be late 80s uh maybe even
early 90s but uh wow wonderful wonderful
lovely uh thank you for the question
yeah I think a lot of grand Masters
are very fortunate when an opening is
named after them because it's often
happens that Grandmasters have the same
ideas same novel
Novelties but they don't get a chance to
play them
wow somebody else beats them to the
punch please I was okay so bear in mind
I was only 11 years old but I was
mightily annoyed at the time that Nigel
Shaw got the credit for the short attack
a short variation in the advanced
carrier because I was like I was playing
no no we're free Bishop E2 no way if you
think about it it's very natural for a
kid to do that I mean the kid is not
gonna go Knight C3 right so you're
playing on the white side
this young Prodigy and nobody's paying
attention to your games but you played
Knight F3 like everybody that's the
thing I think is the most natural move
on the board and then you follow it up
with Bishop E2 and you chase you you
want you want the lighter Square Bishop
right and then you kind of want to
overrun so it's just a very natural
scheme of development from the
Scholastics yeah I mean to be honest and
I was I remember I was so annoyed I was
like why did he get that that when I've
been doing it right he's been copying
you all of these years he gets all the
credit uh anything like that happen to
you Christian that you had some really
wonderful novel idea and somebody else
got the credit well I like to uh call it
the Count's Gambit do you know the
town's Gambit no I don't know the counts
okay E4 uh Knight
sorry what's the content all right well
we're not going to get terrible this is
terrible okay okay D4 Knight F6 oh sorry
Bishop G5 D4 Knight F6 so the trumpovsky
bishop G5 the Trump yes okay Knight to
E4 Knight to E4 yes and now if you go
Bishop four yep now I go E5 oh that's
the comments
you take only five yeah I'll show you
the one tricky with the pawn or the
bishop with a pawn let's say you take
with the pawn okay now I go D5 D5 yes
now you're like I'm super happy I can
take on D6 as well right not so fast
Queen F6
now you get into some sort of uh oh oh
my Spidey Sense is tickling ah this is
the count scam if you take on C7 yeah
Knight C6 wow three Pawns and I have
great compensation in fact you're kind
of worse at this point wow so try it out
because amazing I remember I'm sure a
lot of other people are playing it right
I remember we analyzed this
um in a Romanian Olympic team Camp many
many years ago maybe like a decade and a
half ago and we came up with the
conclusion that this is playable in fact
Knight to E4 Bishop to F4 uh and E5 the
problem is that nowadays not a lot of
people play beach before after Knight to
E4 they play Bishop page four sometimes
they even go H4 in the position so it's
not that easy to get the counts Gambit
uh on the board I remember the fide
president florencio
was in Linares I was playing in a
tournament uh there at Linares and Campo
was in the media center and he was
playing uh black
against uh lazarovich the women's
Grandmaster from Yugoslavia and he
played
Queen C7
and Campo was actually a pretty good
chess master and he played in a number
of uh teams on the Philippines and I
said
Campo what are you doing
and here it comes you know what he said
to me
he said I'm playing the compo Khan
[Laughter]
self-anoided openings but I tell you how
openings get their names
I mean they're all over the map it's
really really terrible I mean some of
them are named after animals
yeah and even the karakan Mr Khan
according to my research yes there's
very little to do with the opening right
it was this collaboration no there was
no collaboration because Mr Marcus Khan
died before this alleged collaboration
even began yeah I mean it doesn't make
any sense but somehow other he's become
like associated with an opening that he
had very little to do with and it was
all Horatio carro's work and then you if
you think about a really really really
great I mean just simply outstanding
player uh like laosh portishe of Hungary
like this guy played an eight candidates
Cycles I mean he's a world champion
Contender for decades and he's played
just about everything under the Sun but
you've never heard of the a portishe
attack or the portishe Gambit or the
portishe variation laosh portishe is one
of the great players he's played
everything but nothing got his name
didn't get connected with any particular
that I'm aware of at least so yeah how
it happens great question uh
but uh let's just uh Christian if you
don't mind uh just update the game of
Wesley and I'll do the same for Alice
and uh so it seems like after night of
D7 I believe this is where we left it
off C takes D6 Knight to diesel so c66
was indeed played Knight to D7 defending
reinforcing the defense of this complex
uh supported by Bishop the pawn on E5
and queen to F2 not F5 not Rook C5 this
exchange sacrifice but Queen to F2 was
played this is where we stand you have a
couple of options as black you can take
on F4 though at least to my practical
eyes doesn't make that much sense F6 is
the one move that I'm looking at you
don't want be careful don't take on D6
first because after taking on E5 you
have some problems on F7 you take I take
back take and take on F7 this gives
white uh the decisive Advantage so this
is the idea behind this move Queen to F2
and I'm expecting
a quick F6 that's just going to defend
once again uh the the pawn on E5 no more
problems on the f file whenever you take
I'm in fact going to take back with the
Knight and at some point I'm going to
Corral well it's very soon I'm going to
grab that pawn on D6 and pick it up with
the queen which should allow me to
equalize this position as black and how
about the Alice Lee uh defending that
position against Irina crush with the
pawn down how is that going yeah well
and I must say Arena's uh play you know
really has this uh beautiful logic I
want to say behind it she played this
quiet move Bishop D2 against Bishop C7
she played again Bishop D3 and you think
to yourself what exactly is she doing
well she's anticipating Queen B6
threatening Queen takes H2 she's leaving
her Knight to defend the square and
after a move like
um G5 it's one of those positions where
you know we're castled on opposite
planks therefore you attack me on the
um uh King side I'm going to attack you
on the queen side and I think that her
intention is something like A3 and B4 or
even more concretely Rook B1 and let's
go B4 and she's thinking to herself if
we ever get these positions I'm going to
lead my Rook behind put my Rook on F2 my
King's going to be perfectly safe maybe
maybe Black's King is going to have a
problem don't forget I got a pawn in my
pocket I like Arena's position as we go
on break yeah I like it too and we are
going to take a short break oh
wait a minute
I'm the birthday don't be giving the
cupcakes
this is the Central West End cupcakes
right yeah there's a special shop that
makes this dude I'm gonna go um I got
the chocolate the chocolate I got the
chocolate okay bro oh okay go ahead
hands off
I'm going to get myself all dirty I'll
mash my Mash into my face well thank you
thank you once again happy birthday
we're gonna enjoy these I will see you
on the other side
foreign
[Music]
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
meet me at the beauty
in Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
me the beauty in Forest Park
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
final and here we see the match-ups it
is the top seed Arena crash against 13
year old Wonder kid Alice Lee and we
also have in the open section Hikaru
Nakamura facing off against the mighty
Oasis in a rematch of one of their
earlier matches and things have really
heated up with the Alice League game she
did go for that battery that we've been
talking about the bishop on C7 the queen
on D6 eyeballing that pawn on H2 and I'm
I'm forcefully reminded of the story of
Boris basket Boris basket told me that
when he was a young boy in St Petersburg
he had an opponent that loved to make
these batteries and when Boris would
block them with a move like F3 F4 his
shoulders would slump like
ah he saw it Alice is doing her best to
break open the things on the queen side
this is where I was kind of going for
either a rook B1 and or an A3 you're
getting punches thrown at me on the king
side I want to do the same on the queen
side A3 B4 but maybe there's a more
direct path for maybe Arena Rook to C1
is an interesting idea as well followed
by Queen to B3 once again it's all about
this idea of living the Knight on E2 and
I think she did this masterfully I have
to say Irina she really got what she
wanted in the position she anticipated
perfectly this idea of Bishop C7 Queen
D6 and G5 did not get attracted to that
idea of playing Knight to C3 and then
having to return back to defend the pawn
on F4 she did this masterfully and right
now she's in pole position to take the
full point home I was gonna ask
is there any danger
moving because
I think I was thinking you know if I'm
Alice my dream would be okay so you went
Roxy one
yeah oh yes yeah yeah okay
I mean I've been sitting next year for
eight days I I know you you bring out
the mallets the iron gloves and you go
for the king okay yes and you go
Queen B3 B3 okay I leave you to pursue
right so I don't think porn takes born
does anything great so I think in G5 G4
sorry G4 G4 push on G4 and then you do
but what's next is the question G3 is
what's next and then I go H3 and then I
want to go at some point
and then G2 and then Queen E3 and then
you're like okay
Rook F3 Queen E3 did you just say 26 26
Queen E6 sorry I'm really bad actually
with my corner coordinates
oh did you want to do it with you want
to do queen E6 immediately no yeah but
the problem is King G2 that was why you
wanted G2 but yeah boy I've kind of
stopped well there is hang on a second
before I yes yes yes yes
there is Rook G3 in the air I admire yes
but the problem is
it's my turn
I mean okay the kind of things that
maybe Alice I think he is thinking about
yeah this is where you were headed but
that's the problem you start getting
desperate right right it feels almost
like desperation and if it doesn't work
you're just a piece and a lot a lot of
Pawns down right so yeah this G4 also
from a visual perspective once you play
G4 you know that you're not opening up
the position unless you sacrifice
something right and if those sacrifices
don't work then you're just in trouble
you go H3 I go G3 you go G3 I go H3 and
I close the position and what about the
other option which is
I've changed my mind I said okay
I will not go for this kind of hacker
attack instead you go for my d-pawn I
will just defend okay I will resolutely
put my kitten King on ba yeah and then
once you come to C5 I'm just gonna
let's let's put some moves on exactly
right maybe bishop B6 uh yeah
yeah okay okay okay
he's being mean I'm getting my attack
going I mean hang on there's not a yeah
Knight E5 I take on B7 and then take on
C7 uh probably here is where I I misled
you uh maybe we should have played
instead of the move Bishop E6 just
Bishop back we've got it defended and
then on this
move away but isn't this sad I mean it's
the one attacking you right now exactly
not what you plan from no no I I'm still
a pawn down I feel it should be fine I
mean but if if what I'm trying to say is
that if you just simply keep defending
and you still keep up the pressure on
the king side yes
is that enough to kind of it doesn't I I
don't think it's the compensation I
don't think it's sufficient for
compensation uh I know what you're
saying that you've got this attack
Brewing but uh well I've got a lot of
Defenders uh the night on e2s doing a
yeoman's job The Rook on F1 even if you
did double your Rooks on the G file I do
have Rook F2 so there are a lot of bits
it is like that he like the British
there are a lot of bits on the king side
is that not is that an American no
no say bits
pieces I got pieces depending my we're
not bits
yeah really no I mean you that's British
all the way trust me I've got license to
speak that sounds British
Queen B3 well Arena says I've got enough
Defenders let me uh let me full control
uh I'm calling it right now she she has
absolutely no problems solving her
situation with the King on the king side
no problems
lots of Defenders and I don't see a way
through I don't see any entry squares
that was the point that Jovi was making
earlier on the broadcast there's no
entry squares anymore right and I feel
safe look I feel safe and I'm launching
my own attack on the queen side Irina is
feeling it right now she knows that she
has a great advantage and she knows that
it's much more comfortable for her to
play because again psychologically
you've been attacking you've been
sacrificing and your attack is not going
anywhere and now you're the one on the
defensive at least lead that is
psychologically that is a very difficult
thing to accept and I don't think she
will accept it she will try to find
something on the king side but there's
nothing there moment it doesn't see as
we looked at our graphic we came on yes
yes yes yes the lopsided score between
these two ladies big time in favor of
Arena but then I'm thinking come on 13
years old Arena's uh taking advantage of
uh the the youth uh Alice but the
reality is is that this is beginning to
have its impact I mean for Alice it's
like she's she threw a Gambit early on
got an initiative and the initiative has
dissipated it kind of hurts when you're
when when you can't you know land a blow
against your opponent I was by Alice's
choice of opening to
because in the earlier encounters and
all throughout the tournament she's kind
of Alice has been relying on her trusted
like Sami slaves yes exactly and then to
switch from that and play like an E4 C4
E5 opening which again there's black and
also Alice is not an E4 player she is a
sicilian player but she's not an E4
player so I'm thinking that perhaps some
unfamiliarity with the opening
hindsight's 2020 at the time we thought
that she it had she played that move H3
earlier it was a Gambit that was going
to pay dividends not so anymore after
this move Queen B3 Arenas in pole
position let's take a look at the open
section and when we left it we kind of
left it here we just saw the move Queen
F2 uh eyeballing that F7 Pawn is Hikaru
Nakamura and uh wanting to play uh F4
takes E5 is white F7 F6 uh
you know that's the type of move when I
play it I always reward myself of pat on
the back because I played this move
purposely for two reasons I shut down
the rook and I shut down the bishop
right with the move F7 F6 I'm closing
the diagonal and I'm in a sense kind of
closing the action on the f-file so
those little petite little moves like F7
F6 really uh I stop and say to myself
very good yes sir very good it takes on
F4 E5 takes on E5 takes on E5 Knight
takes E5 Wesley sang
I'm just taking whatever it is that you
you're you're throwing at me and uh
Christian uh what is the follow-up for
Hikaru there's a few follow-ups but the
position Still Remains very balanced
right now Rook C1 makes a lot of sense
even Bishop takes E5 if you try to
simplify the position as much as
possible Bishop takes E5 Queen takes C5
follow it up with D7 don't go into this
end game because after take take I am
picking up an extra Pawn on A3
potentially but even corralling this
spawn on D6 might give black the
advantage right we don't want to see
these type of positions on the board now
what you do want to see on the board as
white is after taking on E5 Queen takes
E5 go D7 use this Pawn as the weapon
that it is and now I go Rook to d8 Rook
to D1 or queen to A2 first so that you
protect the pawn on A3 now the question
is do you want to go King to h8 and
allow Queen to F7 the protection of the
d-pawn from F7 also that attacks the
pawn on F2 it feels a bit too active for
white so what black has to do is offer
the queen trade and this seems to be
just a draw you go here yes you go on
the seventh rank I go towards your Pawn
for who
it's unclear right for who because I am
corralling the pawn on D7 I am about to
pick up the pawn on A3 as well what I'm
seeing is
a lot of exchanges you take you take I
take or I take on D7 first you can take
on B5 or take on D7 take take and we get
this type of position which seems to be
just
um yeah material is too simplified
there's not that much play left in the
position you're going to take this one
I'm going to take the pawn on A3 and
we're most likely going to head towards
a draw this seems to be the natural
conclusion of this game
the players have been playing a really
good game so far I have to say very very
precise they're not giving their
opponents any sort of chances in the
position Hikaru is trying Hikaru is
putting a lot of pressure but Wesley is
very accurately defending and it seems
like right now the position will be
simplified and I have feeling these
players will reach a draw agreements and
if I try to exploit the current moment
of the pin with the move Rook on C1 te1
pitting the Knight and trying to pick it
up very careful don't take on D6 that's
the point I was hoping I was hoping
and I'm eyeballing F7 in case of the
Knight moves and I'm also wanting to
take so it's just too many uh pins right
exactly so you have to go Queen D5 get
off the pin right from D5 which protects
the very critical Square F7 right that's
the key and so after Queen takes Knight
I have Knight D3 now D3 you're forking
my rook and queen takes takes and I D7
you keep I still keep contact with the
pawn on F7 with a square F7 exactly so
Queen D5 is actually that's the only
move everything else looks winning for
white that's right but Queen D5 uh saves
it saves it no Wesley is so good when
calculating these type of positions
let's not forget what he did against
Levon he just took every Pawn in Berlin
that was amazing Bishop takes each two
Knight takes A2 he took the pawns he
took the exchange accurately defended if
I Rook V8 he gave nothing back Rook ba
defend everything no problem that was a
great pressure me with this type of
Bluffs and this is exactly what he's
doing right now there's no Bluffs
remaining I think we're going to see a
liquidation of the pieces exchanges
exchanges going to the end game and make
a draw and uh yeah it's going to be what
we saw with the white pieces tomorrow
right I remember playing a game against
Hurrican
and uh
I wasn't it was in an awkward position
and I decided to go for a bluff where I
even threw a pawn through a rook just
exactly in the same style as Lavon he
just carefully took everything called my
bluff
[Music]
nicely played I mean sometimes it
doesn't work I mean and uh well that was
uh that was quite the game by Wesley uh
he's taking everything as Wesley and by
the way he's defending this position
really very very uh accurately which is
his
we have a tweet a tweet okay challenge
the commentators that's what I asked
marzipan on YouTube keep us in the
Hikari so games what plans would you
consider to take the game from a draw to
pushing for a win well hikaru's doing
exactly what he hoped to do if you go
back to somewhere let's say around these
parts right here and if you ask me the
question that marzipan does I say how
are you going to win this position as
white and I say well that's very simple
you see my Bishop on B2 I'm going to
blast open that diagonal I'm going to
blast open this diagonal so I can
capture this Knight on F6 and then land
a Checkmate over there so look what uh
Hikaru did he played the move F4 to
blast open the diagonal he played C5 so
that he could undermine the E5 pawn and
he's done everything he can to achieve
his Trump which is the bishop on B2 now
the diagram channels open but
unfortunately Wesley has defended it
very very accurately but this is the way
you're supposed to try to win put your
trumps to work in this case it was the
bishop sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't
yeah I mean also
thank you for the question I also like
the questions sometimes you know you
have to start from a position of slight
superiority to push for that win because
one is equal and there's no way through
sometimes you have to accept it is what
it is right
and we also have another tweet okay
today we're having enjoyment and uh
Jason says what has surprised you most
through the tournament so far also happy
birthday well thank you very much for
the best birthday wishes uh in for me
I'm just so pleased that the tournament
has met my highest expectations I came
in I knew the format was going to
generate a lot of decisive games lots of
Thrills and Spills but it exceeded even
that so I'm just elated by the
tournament I I really a big shout out to
the players I mean it's so easy to
commentate when the players are really
giving it their all and when you look at
for example what Naji has done
throughout the tournament what Lavon did
in the Elimination Brackets
they played great guys jump in I mean
this tournament has been a wonderful
event to call it has been you know the
fighting Spirit has been immense for me
the biggest surprise of the whole event
is how few playoffs they were there were
in the women's section
s there were a lot of decisive
Encounters in the class in the classical
and I wasn't expecting that I thought I
thought that there would be play a lot
more playoffs we haven't yet and Alice
were so dominant and Alice of course had
a playoff but it was a rapid payoff no
we haven't seen Blitz and we haven't
seen any Armageddon
just being a surprise jump in Christian
what has been the big surprise of the
event so far for me it was
um hikaru's
handling of the black pieces especially
hikaru's Sicilian I haven't seen Hikaru
actually the Sicilian especially not
such an off-beat line the Kalashnikov
where you usually play the schweshnikov
you play maybe an idorph but a
Kalashnikov with the black pieces
successfully so let's not forget he
defeated Wesley so if I'm not mistaken
in the blitz portion that was a great
great example of how dangerous his
opening preparation has been as well as
Lanier the game against linear and that
was in my opinion the Highlight for
hikaru's performers that that game was
so clinical so beautiful and all his
calculation that he was doing we were
looking at the game with the engine and
we still couldn't understand exactly
what he wants he understood exactly what
he wants that Knight to D4 Knight to
seat y d had to put the Knight on C4
that was alien chess and uh I have to
say Hikaru deservedly took down linear
in that match and smoothly went on to
the Grand finals I think we're we're
kind of under appreciating the effort
that Arena has also put in and again
because her way to the Grand Final was
kind of so smooth we just kind of like
shrug our shoulders took it for granted
but the only reason she's so successful
is because she really plays accurate
chess and her choice of openings at
times very very cagey but I mean when
you think about
you know her end game middle game
strategies everything she puts it
together and except for that moment
where she just lost
virtually on time I mean it was one
second uh she's been
she's been impressive she's been a very
impressive started a tournament with
three victories right and like you say
you know I've been impressed by her
Precision yeah yeah and how she's been
able to put it together in critical
moments and take advantage of those
mistakes
we see Arena champion and what do we
have uh in the game
and Wesley's game Knight takes E5 Rook
C1 we did see rook and now we're
expecting Queen to D5 uh and it does
seem like it's one of the only moves in
the positions so you have to be very
very careful careful right big pivotal
moment right now for Wesley don't do
anything but Queen to D5 but if he does
find the move Queen to D5 then I think
he's out of the woods right now and
we're going to see the simplification uh
is there any way that I mean again the
the trump card in the position is this
Pawn on D5 is there any way I can
somehow manage to how would you do that
yeah well obviously Rooks belong behind
past Pawn get the pawn to B6 yes get the
queen pardon me get the pawn to D7 go
back Queen B6 36 yeah go back to E6 sure
okay once again it's all about that F7
pawn queen one of these lies let's go
Queen D7 yeah oh Queen decent yeah and
I'm stopping both the pawn and your
attack on B7 okay sure wait wait wait
wait yes
D7 okay right here yes okay I was afraid
of Rook d8 Rook D5 right maybe even Rook
D5 yeah I was I think Rook D5 just picks
up the pawn like Queen 87
erupt D5
and we do have Queen D5 on the board
yeah
yeah I think that same business as
before uh we're just trading too many
pieces uh you simplify you take on D5 I
take on D5 you take on B7 I take on D7
and
we make a draw yeah
otherwise uh who who ended up with the
past deep on wait a minute I mean there
was a passive
Christian I I mean good Quincy good
morning St Louis uh yes yeah if for some
reason uh Queen D7 I had just blocked
myself from thinking that because I had
seen this move Queen C7 and I thought oh
oh this is what you want to avoid now my
pet Rook da kind of puts the kibosh on
my uh brilliant idea of warming my way
in uh current position uh any trickies
that no trickies no no trickies and if
you do go Rook to D1 first yep I think I
just have Knight D3
nonetheless huh yeah just 93. wow
walking into a pin no worries
what about group 333
[Music]
what about activating please show me to
H4 but then I have a rookie two right
and I'm starting to put some nasty
pressure on G2 I was kind of hoping my
queen G4 would be quite good but uh yeah
I don't have any time the problem is the
B2 uh Bishop is hanging to The Rook
um Knight D3 kind of strange that
there's no way of exploiting that it
works right yeah like darn it yeah uh
these seven no Queen takes decent you've
got this rookie three to defend the
night and
that's it yeah I mean okay uh
asked and answered I think that's a very
good
Queen E2 okay
these are the trickies that I was trying
for
why didn't we ask that question that's a
good question that is a good question
but uh
is it F3
one move I had
I mean that is a strange move but it
does stop these in case of my king ever
has to go
to F7 it does stop Rook takes F4 check
so
I'm thinking it's a do Christian Jump
Right In I'm thinking this move Queen E2
does test black a little
test black or tests white
okay that's that's her determination
what do you do I I gotta take it you
gotta take it now I go Knight G6
and I gotta take it you're gonna take on
E8 I'm gonna take back and get them to
take it and game how do we so two Rooks
versus the queen be careful you might be
getting checkmated if you're not paying
attention well there is Rick B8 yeah
I better pay attention otherwise uh but
the Rook will capture on G7
and defend you too I like the way you're
thinking there well it does
it's a bit shaky
don't rattle my confidence but I I
understand what he's saying if I go C5
pardon me I'm not gonna allow you to
take on B7 I'm gonna go with C5
see 6 C5 wow
um who's playing for what who's playing
for a victory right now well that's the
thing normally when you have the queen
against the Rooks the opposing King has
to be vulnerable the Rooks can outplay
the queen but if the opposing King is
vulnerable then the queen cannot uh can
can overwhelm the Rooks now this
position to my way of thinking both
kings are vulnerable so then it becomes
a judgment call
do you think whites King's more
vulnerable than black absolutely
you do I do I uh because you know as
Christian highlighted and like comes to
our Four Queens comes down to D2 right
and I mean also
combination of the white works right
they're not selling it let's put it that
way well if the Rook was on E1 I get to
go Rook takes B7 it's like the black
king gets mated yeah existence so I mean
I thought both kings were very
vulnerable just a moment let's have a a
stop right here
and uh
hmm very intriguing position I have to
say very very intriguing position this
one is starting to get a bit imbalanced
and the path towards equality is very
narrow for both sides in fact so let's
go Rook to B8 okay
C5 to defend it's all about the idea of
preventing one of the Rooks of going to
the G file because if you do land on the
G file you defend against all these
ideas of Knight F4 Queen takes Queen to
G5 check Queen to G2 made right so you
defend against this upcoming attack
as you predicted Rook to E1 is the best
move
after C5 keep going yes sir yep Rook to
E1 yeah that's the move right if you
don't play rookie one you're actually
lost wow so if you take on C5 and You're
Expecting
Queen takes C5 check no no no I'm not
touching that part now that I defended
on B7 I'm going to go Knight to four and
how do you defend against Queen G5
it doesn't seem like there's a way right
right this gives uh black the advantage
a winning advantage in fact so you have
to go uh Rook to E1 I can take on B4 yes
that's the plan that's exactly the plan
Rook to E7 King G6 Rook takes G7 and
that's going to be good for white
because it defends that important score
G2 no
that's a bad move
you have to go Rook to E4 now
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you have to
stop the knight from getting into play
with Knight to F4 or Knight to H4 why is
I mean you know
I'm still banking
if you take I will go Knight to F4
and then we go into this line
and now you're getting close
to getting checkmated
that Knight and queen combinations the
only way out is to go D7 I pick up this
guy and now you go H4 yeah
and then perhaps you're surviving
perhaps you're surviving wow but this is
not
and by the way Hikaru when he played
that move Queen to E2 he needs to have
calculated all of these lines or at
least
assume that he's going to be fine
nevertheless with such a weaking on G1
that's not the clear Assurance to my
eyes at least not from a practical
perspective it's easy to see it with the
engine right but without the engine not
so easy but by the way I we also have to
emphasize that for Wesley he has to find
the move F4 F3 if he goes in he does
those variations he doesn't pardon me he
doesn't that's not his only move it is
not his only move no I'm I apologize if
he played Knight G6 yeah he can go
Knight G6 as well but isn't this just
simply better for white no no king of
seven Rook B8
I can probably take on a D6 take on D6
take
this is where I thought my king the
white king is safe and the black king
was not the black kid yeah yeah the
blacking Heights
there you go hiding in plain sight just
a second and the immortal words of uh
Ben Larson nobody believes you you're
King Heights where does your king hide
you want to be careful if you allow me
to get too far up the board than you
might your own King might be in danger
because of my king your king keep going
where let's go to G4 no not afraid of
anything oh but you can't take the pawn
though because Queen D2 is a nice
counter to that that's right
I feel tasered
I'm sorry
I ganged up no no no not at all I mean I
just I heard the king hides and I was
like hides how does a king hide okay I
don't want to allow this F3 I don't want
to allow this queen D2 but
come on come on
come on can I really be worse here is
why no I don't think you're worse
[Music]
wait a minute I was not sure you're
getting out of you can get out of the if
you if white wanted a draw you can go
Rook after Rook F1 no no no I'm not
going to give him a draw no way I'm
giving him I was gonna go Rook to G7
again because I was told by you by the
way that if I put my Rook on G7 I defend
G2 uh I'm par I'm I'm I've been promised
to sweetness in Paradise Yasser needs to
work for his draws so I'm going to give
you a check on E3 check on E3
now I don't want no stink and draw to us
Rook up to right yeah yeah I don't know
but nobody's going to take on A3 right
no no no no no I'm not even not looking
at your pawns no no okay hang on by the
way he did not play F3 he played Knight
C4 whoa whoa whoa whoa this is a totally
different kettle of fish that's uh let's
review uh let's refresh and go to the
current position he didn't play Knight
G6 he didn't play F3 the two moves we
were looking at he chose the third move
Knight C4 and what does the engines uh
think about this one
you probably can guess it right zero
zero no yes
again I'm thinking that Black's King is
more vulnerable than white house and
I've got it wrong but how is this zero
zero I mean you you give a check it's
not that easy so you give a check you
have to give a check right right
otherwise you lose a right King G6
only move only thing else is losing okay
yes yes
and
now you need to move a bishop right
we're on pre yeah I would put on A1 just
because it's with it okay fair fair
you put it on A1 do we it's because we
gobble up the spawn let's pick up punk
F7
Jovi uh a task and you shall get it yes
King G5 let's defend that pawn I mean
you're attacking my Pawn I gotta play
logical chess right
I am
I have heard him being this facetious
logical Jess
and well we do have Rook E7 as a Prelude
to be king coming and Wesley just like
me right King placed it out king the G6
let's Blitz it out
um yeah this is the position this is the
positions precisely this position where
I would say the two Rooks are going to
overwhelm the black side because I'm
looking at whites King I'm saying you're
pretty darn safe good job
Black's King no you're not safe uh I
should I should have the advantage so
this is what I think we will be seeing
okay instead of Bishop to A1 what my
prediction is
is that Hikaru has seen a way to
simplify the position in case he needs
it so no
rotations
I'm going to take on F4
hang the bishop on B2 yes
which forces matters because now I go to
F7
the F Rook yes and now there is no way
to defend the gas Perpetual there's
prepared and also D7 is a
so for example if you try to get away
from the Perpetual with Queen D3 and
let's say you want to sacrifice the
queen for the two Roots you can uh you
take it's a three seven exactly yeah so
you cannot do that you have to accept
the draw you can give a check on D1 and
King F2 and then you can try to say that
oh wait but my knight gets back into
play with Knight D3 but then I get close
to the Knight with King to E3 and you
don't have a follow-up
the Perpetual is coming you know I've
got to prepare it wow uh I'm still uh
confounded by this
by this position and I I was really
thinking that Hikaru was for Choice with
the two Rooks uh it just happens that
this bishop on B2 is under attack
because you know the desirable D7 the
desirable Rook G4 and let's set up
Bishop you know mating patterns it all
feels like it should be good for white
good grief uh that is that's remarkable
wow
um and and once again you we had Ruka
but wow that's presupposing though that
hikara wants a draw
Hikaru perhaps knows that he has a draw
in case he cannot find anything else
right
so he probably saw this whole line he uh
saw Rook takes F4 and he can pull the
brakes whenever he wants it seems like
so Rook takes F4 Knight takes B2
Rook on F4 to F7 setting up a constant
Perpetual check with Rook H7 if he wants
it yeah is his as you say pulling the
brakes
it's
compounded I almost
I'm gonna return my Grandmaster title in
the v-day office and say uh
well it doesn't really matter the
results of today because tomorrow it's
all determined that which colors and
if the match is tied up to two games we
are going to see playoffs and this will
continue until the match is totally
decided and that and only in case of
Alice Lee and Wesley winning the match
tomorrow will we have playoffs yes
basically Wesley so and Alice Lee in
order to win this
cup the title the title they need to
read like Hikaru twice in the case of
Wesley and Arena twice in the case of
Alice and talking about whilst we leave
those
well that was a bit crazy
my brain hurts things are sharpening
his Arena
grab the pawn on D5 I love it and in
return
Alice got a big phone on G3
okay well
so two pawns up for arena okay when we
left it we left we left it after the
move Queen B3 Rook G8 King H1 boy talk
about playing Just
keeping everything under control uh on
the king side uh G4 now Rook to G1
oh I'm loving this for arena because we
were looking at these positions where
you go G3 H3 or if you go H3 I'll go G3
and I'll keep picking I'll keep the
position close she said I'll have that
one yeah she so she allows G3 H3 is not
possible because if Bishop takes H3 let
me just put that on the board that's a
discovered attack against the queen is
an absolutely true because I I start to
think about Rook C6 don't I
good can I play Rook C6 here
um sorry I uh well you do have um
if you take I've got a check just to
let you know that I do get my queen out
of Dodge Bishop B6 and now we can go g
G2 okay I'm still with you all the way
I know unless you play G1 and maybe you
do play G1 okay uh sorry I just had to
stop and pause there for a moment Irina
said after Bishop takes H3 oops sorry
this is not what arena said after G3
Arena said I will pull back the queen
Queen F3 Bishop G4
and Alice took the Knight what that is a
shocking move
why would you no ever give up you cannot
do that
that is really shocking so I will
happily and I understand you go H3 and
you're saying that you're opening up
she's gonna go H3 ah thank you that's
about three how do you continue opening
up the device
I suppose you have to do this oh G4
there that shuts out down everything
attack is over yeah that is over but if
you
that's fine okay then I take with the
pushes pause for just a second because
there is a queen H3 sighting that uh
okay never mind
and we are here yeah
can I
Rook I sorry I seem to be on a single
track at the moment Rook takes C6 let's
look at it right or D5
Rook takes C6 or D Jovi take it well
that's your instinct do it take it
I don't know if it though the king is
going to go running right I guess the
king gets on this morning issues
King to D7
new piece oh new piece
G2 no I don't like it sorry too
ambitious what about okay so we're here
we're anticipating Bishop takes E2 H3
uh this feels like
irina's got something really good here
so let's keep going Bishop F3
you have to take on G2 first apologies
you're absolutely right we already uh
realized that
okay
I do I do I do I do I want to play you
know and it makes a lot of sense I like
this bishop not being under attack on G2
but uh Christian was looking at this and
I think we were going to go D5 let's
have some no D5 I take on D5 right
I'm not sure if I want to see those type
of positions wow
because there's a rook G1 chat and that
opens up my king right yes
no but can we get ready for that D5 like
Queen F3 or Rook C5 double up on the C5
what if I try to double up on C file
cave Manchester let's let's go Rook C4
or Rook C5
as a a little bit worried that black
might return the favor by doubling up on
the G file right
oops that sorry that arrow that was the
worst Arrow
from all the broadcasts that oh it was
the worst Arrow uh Bishop takes E2 sorry
let's go back just to the the game
position why why do you think Alice took
this uh she could have taken on G2 could
have gone H3 help me out here uh uh no I
think she's looking at exactly what
we're looking at Bishop and she's
assuming that she's going to have enough
compensation via the G file
but okay
let's keep going that that line seems to
be the correct one okay
this is the line that seems to be the
correct one yes take take and you
annoyed me with that move Rook to G3 so
I'm going to try to stop you I'm going
to go Queen F3 Queen F3 immediately why
not
make sense doubles
okay uh we don't we don't know we don't
know but now I go D5 now you go D5 Rook
doubles
you're not afraid you're getting checked
maybe first well I mean yeah who lands
there first with the most right
I mean there is this
well that's not really a threat maybe
this is the threat how is the position
after Queen takes G2
no I well should we talk once again
about the two Rooks versus the queen
position it's all about the
vulnerability of the King right
and whose King is more vulnerable it
feels like white skin
is the more vulnerable but the the game
of Hikaru
has thrown me
off my my my guiding principles my
beacon of light has turned to Darkness
but it's also to do with peace
coordination and take a look at White's
works not very no they're not very good
I don't like it yeah so let's go back
let's go back but you know what I'm
actually thinking I like yasu's idea of
going Queen takes porn
you know I can I I can withstand
everything except flattery
flattery Works
terribly well in my case
um
okay follow follow it up with something
brilliant because I I wasn't doing it
Queen Jack
or Bishop check yeah which one do we
like okay Queen check yeah let's have
some fun and go right okay are we ready
is it time yeah now there's thinking
this idea of D5 right
D5 and then I want to follow that up
with Bishop Bishop C3 or even Rook takes
in Bishop C3 Bishop right right and I'm
thinking that we've got to be guided by
that Beacon of light that is full when
your king is under attack trade Queens
Golden Rule I'm waiting for the angels
to start singing here you know just as
simple it's just so simple wow
um
uh Christian I've got great news for our
commentary panel we've sold Jeff
okay you thought it was complicated not
anymore folks we've solved chess here it
is the guiding guiding principles are
Beacon of light
uh Queen takes G2 and queen H3 check and
D5 we're we're ready to rock and roll uh
take on C7 Bishop C3 you you got the
worst positions
see I told you chess was easy how did we
get the worst position I'll take the
pawn queen takes B2 and I'm attacking
the bishbon G2 at the same time how do
you defend against all my threats if you
take on C6 I have a feeling you're gonna
get checkmated not only after Queen
takes D2 but Rook to G1 seems to be
finishing it one Rook to G1 take take
there's some cobwebs
yeah that's beautiful oh that's
beautiful
Bishop H5 which page five and now I just
take my Bishop yeah
the king is still weak right oh my so
there are some pitfalls in the position
but Bishop takes C2 still on the board
still thinking okay let's keep going
taking with the queen is Is Not Great
okay you have to take back with the
bishop it seems like take on H2 and now
Queen F3 okay this is the position we
were looking at right oh hang on I got
an idea yes Rook C2
so Rook G7 Rook C2 do the Soviet School
of Defense okay and then the bishop just
moves yes and a friend defend it
everything is defended
Soviet School of Defense it works
it works they just if you think about it
stabilize the position you have the two
Bishops you have the pawn up you have
the great structure your only problem is
the fact that you're getting checkmated
wrong everything else has gone right but
the thing is but black doesn't have any
other scheme of attack in the position
this Knight cannot move you get
checkmated on B7 the bishop doesn't
really have where to go right there's no
targets and this block of Pawns on dark
swears are doing a marvelous job against
bespawn C7 there's no way to invade with
a queen so if you stop exactly as Jovi
pointed out if you stop the only counter
shot on the G file then you're just
simply winning I'm going to be able to
have all the time in the world to set up
my own attack Rook to C1 D5 then you
have your own problems on the C file
you're getting checkmated first on the C
file so yeah this is it just take on F3
put a Pawn uh G2 get the queen to
F3 and then defend Rook C2 Bishop P1
Rook C1 counter attack and that's it
game over
we did it you sold the chest with your
soul chess as we get ready to go on
break uh with this last move uh no draw
says Hikaru I'm not going to play The
Rook takes F4 Rook F7 I am going to play
like Jovi I'm playing for the win with
the move Bishop A1 did he make the right
choice we'll find out is we'll take a
break and we'll see on the other side
[Music]
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year it
all kicks off in March with the second
edition of the American cup with 16
players across two Fields fighting for a
300 thousand dollar prize fund in this
double elimination tournament with both
classical and Rapid time controls for
the first time since 2020 the Cairns cup
is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back
starting with the spring chess Classic
on April 5th the summer chess classic
August 2nd followed up with the St Louis
Norm Invitational and the winter chest
classic wraps up the year in December
September brings back everyone's
favorite chest night on legs where some
of the world's best don't even know
what's coming and compete for a 150
thousand dollar prize fund 30 players
across three Fields come together in St
Louis for the U.S juniors girls and
Senior championships starting July 15th
in partnership with U.S chess the best
in the U.S fight to be the nation's best
and a 400 000 prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
Chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels
it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best join
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
Zagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions and our Galleries and sign
up for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh back and it is game one of the first
championship final or grand finale as
we've been calling it absolutely and I
was just really stunned by the move of
Hikaru Nakamura as he played the move H4
and it was like a dark curtain came over
me as I didn't understand what's going
on and in case you're joining us late in
case you're joining us here are the
match-ups we have Arena crash the
highest rank player in the female
competition she is facing off against 13
year old Alice Lee whereas Hikari
Nakamura who headlines the event he
faces off against Wesley so and it's
been exciting games in both matches and
it's been very exciting because this is
all the prelude for the action that is
going to be happening tomorrow as the
matches will be decided now hirina and
Hikaru as the winners of the Champions
bracket right they have an extra life
they do have an extra life so they can
afford to lose their match tomorrow
right and then there will be an extra
day of Rapid playoffs whereas if either
Wesley or Alice lose the match that's it
yeah it's finished uh we left it just
about these this uh we thought that
Hikaru was going to play the move Rook
takes F4 and then after Knight takes B2
to make a comfy draw as white with the
move Rook on F4 to F7 as we've already
got a Perpetual Hikaru spotted something
the position that I was completely blind
to he played Bishop A1 Knight E3 I
thought white was in trouble Knight on
Knight attacks The Rook on F1 attacks
the pawn on D6 what are we going to do
about it H4 says Hikaru take my Pawn
take my rook and in either case I've set
up a very
very nasty Bishop G7 check and mate for
those reasons
Wesley said Queen to D3 and suddenly the
game is extremely sharp or maybe it's
not is it is it going to be one of those
triple zeros Christian that we're so
commonly see it is oh no it is but but
king2f2 was not a correct move Hikaru
had a golden opportunity he could have
went to H2
so Queen came to D3 Rook all the way
until the end captured F4 Queen D1 Queen
D that's that's the game makes sense and
now instead of King F2 King to H2 okay
what do you play now
well I assumed all along that the idea
was to take the bishop it was indeed and
now this is where the key move comes
into play Rook to E7
yes you're taking away Queen E5 I like
it you cannot play Knight D5 or things
of that nature because after uh at the
right moment I will play D7 maybe I'll
give you a check first to E6 follow it
up with E7 and then you have some
problems because you cannot defend
against the promotion so what you have
to do after Rook to E7
oh you do take the bishop yes yes Bishop
is very important Rook to E7 and now you
have to start looking at ideas of Knight
takes G2 in the position and start
looking for it yes start looking for
perpetuals which are not easy to find I
have to say
or queen to E1 sorry not Knight takes G2
first
Knight takes G2 is also a move uh but
Queen 21 makes the most sense at least
from a practical perspective but if you
still push the pawn if you push the pawn
I think I gotta check and I got The Rook
uh
by the way this is once again back into
my ballet work of Tricks uh white king
more safer than Black's King I would
prefer the Rooks right right but you
know what the problem is and I think
this is why Hikaru played King F2 what's
look at the time situation
what is the time eight minutes for
Hikaru with a very very complicated
position still right against 20 minutes
for Wesley so
well how is Wesley supposed to handle
the action after King F2 now you can
just play 95. yeah then get the Knight
back now you play 95 yes get the Knight
back my goodness that wasn't the first
move that came to my mind either I was
thinking Queen takes
um Bishop Bishop as well as Queen D2 we
might see Queen takes Bishop yes and
then after rookie seven once again
Hikaru is in the driver's seat because
Knight defense because of this D7 ideas
you're telling me that Knight D5 whether
you play Rook check or not we can decide
let's go D7 yes and there's no Perpetual
there's there's not enough of a
Perpetual here I'm not convinced you
have the Perpetual wow but isn't there
any Knight takes work and then which
shook yeah well no I'm gonna take the F4
Rook yeah I mean with or without check
right because you know don't go rookie
too don't go rookie too Knight takes a
four and I get back in time to avoid
promotion I guess that is pretty uh
let's just show that to our viewers a
nasty uh night picks up the rook and
stops the pawn from promoting whoa whoa
whoa so this is really sharp sharp stuff
sharp stuff yes and you're saying that
in this exact position avoid taking the
bishop don't take the bishop drop back
attack The Rook take the bishop on the
next turn and stop rookie seven that's
right because with the queen on D1 now
D7 is not possible D7 I'm just simply
going to pick up the Rook on F4 and the
queen defends against the promotion so
okay I am being challenged here no
question about it I'm sure the players
feel the same way but how do you get to
those triple zeros Rook of seven as
before the same idea and you got those
perpetuals and the Knight on D5 still
cannot catch the pawn so you cannot
sacrifice the the queen for the two
Rooks Rook takes H7 King G6 Rook G7 and
unfortunately for black cannot take on
G7 you just simply don't get back in
time exactly take take D7 the Knight is
offsides Jovi are you feeling challenged
this is an amazing game that's going on
here wow wow and also the game of Alice
Lee and uh arena is also taking a very
sharp turns as well and the players in
both games are going to be uh short of
time she did it she did yours did the
reinforcement approach exactly I'm
referring of course to the game of Arena
we had gotten to this position hold on
let me just refresh my board and make
sure I'm up to date with the players we
had gotten to this position and we took
a lot of false turns let's be fair
until we finally actually you finally
latched on to this very key idea of just
defending the bishop by dropping back
and after King B8 now Arena feels like
she's more in control of the position if
she's looking to blast her way down the
um the sea line with the move D5
and how do the engines evaluate this one
I mean First Look Whites Whites do
incredibly well white is cruising right
now uh it's a plus Five Pawns wow
Advantage so this is game over according
to the engines objectively Irena Crush
right now has the full point in the back
wow wow okay I didn't see plus five but
I thought it was double-edged but
apparently if you're not breaking
through on the G1 Square it's game over
well there's a problem with blacks
pieces I mean truly they can't move on
the queen side yep
and if they can't move
that's bad it's really bad news and of
course the bishop and queen holding
everything at Bay and thinking about
talking about the clock times we see
that Alice has just over four minutes
not so much and then Irina well she has
three times more because she has nearly
16 minutes on the clock impressive so
we're back to our uh open game uh
between Hikaru our number one seed King
F2 and here's where Wesley is burning
clock no he took on A1 he didn't play
the move Knight D not 95 he took on A1
and now Hikaru chose Rook to G5 not Rook
to E7
whoa having real hard time following uh
the moves of the game here what's the
idea behind Rook to G5 Checkmate well
you always have this uh I mean no that's
the whole point it wasn't that the point
yes that is just down to the point
precisely the points yes yes but okay I
I get that but if I drop back with a
knight then you're going to push the
pawn push yes yes yes is it so simple I
I dropped back with the queen where do
you draw back oh it's way change it's
very nice so then you have Ricky Rick
evil don't I go Rook F5
what about rookie four thread and
checkmate
hold on tell me what you want I want
Ricky for right rookie
well he's done Knight D5
against this move Rook to G5 and we are
expecting D7
right
right yes yes okay and we did drop back
to stop
the coronation and we wanted Rook F4 to
F5
well I wanted rookie for Christian
wonderwork well the idea behind rookie
four was him yeah there's two folds to
go Rook E6 Checkmate wow check me nearly
Checkmate nearly
yeah now I go check I presume King G1
let's try to hide check and try to hide
yes and let's try to hide
but this is the dollar this is the
Dilemma where is my night going right
wait this Knight B6 does not work
because of d8
90. that's right that that's a worthy
visual that is a very very nice quite
impressive how
yes but that that's what uh my rules of
two Rooks versus Queens are all about
and that the two Rooks are for Choice
when the opposing King in this case
black king is the more vulnerable and we
do have D7 on the board
played it kind of with
well
as if to suggest time trouble is an
issue for now it's not feeling
comfortable with those seven minutes
only he feels the position could still
remain very complex and he wants to keep
it is
any checks by the way can I like ladder
check you like if I go Queen B2 sorry
try it out
try what if I go walking King to G1
check Rook F1 Rook F1 and check right
and now King let's say King where are
you going
let's go H1 use yes as a golden rule
yeah the queen and the Rook even though
I'm not convinced because now whenever
my Rook leaves the uh the first rank you
have Queen E1 Queen takes H4 so in fact
I want to put the King on H2 you do all
right you tricked me with this new rule
of yours it's it's not a rule it's a
guiding principle it doesn't help a lot
but Queen E7
yeah and uh let's take a look at how
Nakamura got through the brackets and
first up he defeated Sam Savion look at
that oh
and he meets Dominguez and there is a
win there no playoffs he keeps winning
in the classical and uh if he
fights against his Nemesis Wesley so
goes all the way to the blitz tie breaks
and he manages to make it to the Grand
Final so there we have it amazing it's
that's five wins four draws and one loss
for the white pieces against wizard
exactly Wesley having to win with uh is
back to the world with the black pieces
um sorry D7 on the board two choices
here Queen B2 check driving the King
backwards and queen h8 uh Christian tell
us what he should do do you like the
checks or is Queen H ate the right
choice Queen h8 is a good move it's a
goodness yes but I have a feeling Queen
B2 probably no Queen B2 actually loses
is losing yes because the king I go up
with the king king to G3 okay
wow
I mean queen B2 check I have to say is
so tempting I mean you always want to
see where your opponent's king is going
to go
but Queen h8 and then you had this
there's another movie four sorry please
removing the position quite interesting
in fact
um which seems to be forcing matters is
Queen to C1
we need to see one threatening The Rook
with a check so you really have no time
to Queen then I'll just make a prepaid
well you probably have not more than
that so yes but why should I not have
more can I not just move the Rook back
to F three if you do that Queen to D2
and after that I uh now I'm behind go 97
right 97 cover my king with Knight G6
and now now life's wonderful because
Rook have six checks yeah sorry perhaps
not that easy anymore right right yeah
so Queen C1
wow Quincy one and the big question is
how is the position of the Rook takes D5
what's the big question again
how is the position of the Rook day's
default okay well can you just take the
Rook take the Rook with a check
I'm there for you
you're oh Queen
the most natural move in the position
against the promotion Rook takes D5 wow
this is really really complicated it's
easy to get lost here so Queen h8 was
like the more most natural Queen B2
check you think about it for a little
minute a while or two you kind of
convince yourself you're only helping
White's King get the safety if you don't
see Queen C1 and I must say it's it
looks like
a strange possibility then Queen h8 and
you say let me put the pressure on my
opponent Queen h8 what's going on here
uh Christian is uh
I mean I'm expecting somebody to tell me
that icaro is playing for a win or he's
playing for a draw like help me out here
what's the objective result well the
objective is still zeros
it's all about yeah the engine will
always find some sort of a Perpetual
here but it's all about that practice
those practical chances right right
so and we think Rook E4 right that was
where we well that's that's the
attack uh yes that's one move a rook F5
was another one that we were considering
Rook ff5 Rook F4 F5 yeah you would be
surprised there's a lot of moves that
keep the balance in the position you
know this is where also I think I was
influenced by uh Robert James Fisher or
Bobby Fisher you know he kind of
convinced My Generation that there was
always
the best move in a position that was the
best movie and look for the best move
now we get to these incredibly complex
positions and the engine says no there's
not just one choice rookie four Rook F5
there's a number of best moves and I I'm
still getting adjusted to that I'm
always thinking it as the best movement
and he's played rookie for on the board
I think in a practical level rookie four
might be a bit more problematic for
black because the other one I mean well
you are looking at this mates you are
looking at rookie eight so yeah rookie
four would definitely in a Blitz game
where I didn't have much time to think
that would be where my hand would go
okay so now I mean I'm thinking this is
really challenging for Wesley because
from Wesley's perspective I mean his
King is constantly being faced with
threats of Checkmate it's not easy yeah
I was going to say queen F6 check is the
one consequence of this move exactly and
you have to step back
because King G3 King G3 Queen D6 check
and you're behind the pawn and maybe now
you're ready too I can take the point
right and even to take the pawn I
apologize for that yes King G1 I have to
step back
so Queen D6 check by the way that stops
both rookie six as well as rookie eight
so that makes it nice
Christine
how's it going how's it going oh it's
it's yeah sorry we thought we lost you
there we saw we really saw the two
thumbs up and we thought we're ready to
jump for you yes or not everything is
for you no it's your birthday not
everything is for look I mean I'm
feeling very special over here I mean I
know it was very flattering the the the
the the the the the you can't find the
solution so that I can play Blitz on
Sunday
I would really love to uh you want to
you want to throw some patties do you
why not right I mean I want to throw it
them against you potentially yeah but I
know you're not going to leave the
commentary Booth I know you're you're
comfy uh we're looking at Queen F6 King
G1 yes and we need uh a follow-up for uh
Wesley well we'll find it out soon
because he's played Queen episode queen
of six and most likely going to see King
G1 effect it's time yes 10 minutes for
Wesley 5 40 for Hikaru okay and after
King G1 we we did spot a very very nice
trick the very nice trick that we did
spot was Knight B6 d8 Queen and oops
that is a visual that uh Hikaru will
remember for a long time and should he
get it in so perhaps you have to go
Queen D6 right
so after King G1 Queen to D6 and he's
reaching first queen so we expect Queen
to D6 which covers the E6 Square while
simultaneously threatens to capture the
pawn on D7
now where are all of these wonderful uh
Perpetual checks that you keep telling
me the engine will find I'll show you
please
Queen D6 on the board which is d8 d8
okay I took us hierarchy six and nine
blocks Rooker five
King joins the party rock takes up six
that's a drawn King opponent game
really wow so this is a drawn King and
pawn ending I can get a
not easy though not easy to to assess it
right wow my first instinct would be I
want to avoid this sorry uh Jovi you
know
white does also have to be careful in
that King opponenting you know because
H5 is could be coming to exactly
sabotage those two pawns on the king
side so something like this this guys
this is dangerous territory I have to
say for Hikaru
this is in fact losing that's what I
would have thought yes
that go back a little bit
before Rook to F5
this is the key concept it seems like
after Knight to F6 I have to start
attacking you with my king king F2 no
yes get lost I mean only move that makes
a draw right now
it's the only move only moving the
position scanner
Chicago has to find all of this within
Karu will Define King F2 in that exact
moment you have to play d8 I think he's
in trouble I think Hikaru is in trouble
right now wow Hikaru is in trouble I
honestly think he will not be able to
find this and Hikaru on
the this is dangerous dangerous
territory for Hikaru and then just say
I've got to look at him shaking his head
yeah and he's kind of his back is
ready he's calculating well it
something about the whole Queen F6 Queen
D6 that he missed when he played the
move rookie four he was clearly focused
on queening the pawn and playing rookie
six and thinking it's all copacetic and
good but once again this whole line
where you go into this
um
King and pawn end game that really wow
right here if you don't play Rook F5 if
you play King F2 but from afar you only
calculate Rook at five right of course
you only calculate Rook F5 and then you
calculate that for like your next three
minutes and you realize that you're
losing and then you panic and you do
something silly and you lose okay right
okay let's let's zoom out I did too yeah
I died and Wesley did too Wesley reached
for his pen and I said what was the move
he played Jovi let's zoom out a little
bit and see hikaru's face because I'm
very curious and and you can usually
read hikaru's Queen the pawn are we
there let's see he's not happy look at
him he's and he's going for this line
okay now it's the critical moment will
he play Big moments right now King F2
only move
if he finds King F2 I'm telling you this
is
that's the wrong side that's the wrong
side that it loses why does it lose it
looks good to me Queen to C7 check okay
I'm still in this terrible pin I don't
quite get it myself okay King H3 I
understand Queen D7 that's good G3 Queen
F7
tickles The Rook from the house
this is over you cannot that so
he's got it right he's got it he's got
it Queen C7 he's got it in the bag if he
says Queen C7 followed by Queen F7 oh
that's nice I mean it is simple and I
would expect but it's a it is nice queen
queen to C7 Queen F7
pressing
uh he did he was avoiding draws is what
I want to say uh and he's not going to
be rewarded Queen C7 check lands on the
board Carlos Hikaru is going to see
instantly Queen F7 because I mean the
threat is made right so you defend the
Knight and you defend the night with
queen of he's trying to maintain his
Poker Face exactly I think he knows it
well Wesley has over and by the way
there's not really too much of a choice
for Wesley either right no I mean
otherwise Wesley really is
uh bound hand and foot you know oh look
at him look at Hikaru hey Karu no he's
not even looking at the position
he knows it he knows he's busted
but will Wesley find it's a little bit
hidden Queen C7 Queen F7 but you're
anxious to
are you thinking about Queen D4 because
you know what the problem is it's not
the only winning move Queen D4 right
Queen f8 also wins Queen f8
now you're hurting me
Queen f8 also wins no Queen D4 is the
one that makes a draw
the same idea of the move King to F2 now
you get the king to G3 to defend that
pawn
and you don't have a way to get back to
F7 wow so now I just sit like this for a
while all about dislodging the work on
E6 exactly I am
mystified you're about to tell me that
Queen f8 also always wins yes well he's
playing Queen D4 he's my goodness he's
missed the queen C7 Queen F7 he missed
it no but this so natural you know it is
he still thinks he's losing well Icarus
thinks he's forced to play G3 and that I
think is what what does lose really you
think he wants to go G3 well no I'm
thinking he thinks he has to play G3
King G3 is not a natural move King G3
makes a draw well at least three
restores the balance objectively let's
see if he finds are shaking his head
maybe Hikaru shaking his head because he
thinks the positions is a draw no no no
no no no no no no no no no Hikaru knows
he's in trouble
well we know that he'd love a draw maybe
he thought he was playing for a win all
along I don't think so in one of these
sentences we know we know
there are known unknowns and there are
unknown unknowns
and let's just uh check in in the
Arena's position I just want to make
sure he plays King King G3 because if he
doesn't then once again he's in a losing
situation but if he did if he does find
it that that's going to be more or less
an objective equality by the way it does
look like arena is well on her way to
winning at the moment
she does have this nice opportunity
going on there 20 seconds for a car will
okay place your bets is it going to go
King G3 or G3 I think he's gonna go King
G3 I think he's going to go King G3 as
well yes it makes sense you know
bringing the king and once if once
you've resigned yourself to the idea
that it could be a draw then you have no
fair King comes out a draw he he would
love a draw in this position well we
know that he doesn't know he doesn't
know that he's not playing for a win no
no he's not shaking his head like that
because he thinks he's playing for a win
well he's shaking his head and his
time's ticking as well as he's under two
minutes and again there is no second
time control in these classical games
it's 90 minutes for the whole game with
only the 30 second bonus to Big moments
right now guys big big moment this in
fact could be the moment of this
Tournament of this title because if
Wesley wins this one and he only has to
make a drop with the white pieces
tomorrow he's going to take that match
all the way to Sunday all the way to
Grand Final Sunday
25 minutes plus 10 seconds is going to
be a rapid match I think it is suffering
you can see he thinks he's lost I'm
telling you he thinks he's lost right
now he's like what did I do I don't know
I don't have the
like the guide on hikaru's gestures
um now he's under a minute imagine him
resigning right now no he's not gonna
resign you don't think he's gonna no
he's gonna just okay I think would be a
bit too big
I think you'll go King G3
he's shaking his head down underneath a
minute 40 seconds and counting yeah
I knew it he comes once you're accepted
I'm saying he's shaking his head because
he thinks he's let Wesley off the hook
that's what I think too he missed Queen
C7 and queen F7 as did Wesley and I
think Wesley is also thinking like okay
I should I should secure the draw and
play uh per Pat
I agree perpetual
sorry uh maybe as we wait for Wesley
we'll just take a quick Gander at what
is going on in the Alice League it is
the last very long I have to say why is
that because can you not just take the
Rook
yes
is this not just going to be game over
and then after we take the Rook you're
gonna hit me with a check or what are we
gonna do
or you were you were you planning to
take the pawn or
is there something completely convincing
wait wait there was something is there
something
well there is a check and there's a
check on C4
so if we go like this
we can uh pick up the bishop
and I don't think there's any Perpetual
checks for Alice in fact you can force
it by going C C7 right at the start from
the very starting position
C7 okay and queen takes work right and
now Bishop takes Rook now
exactly and you just pick up the bishop
for free and there's no Queen G1 uh
mates in the position got it
that's good enough good enough all right
we're going to go back to this game
that's keeping us on the heart The Edge
Let's Stay with this one because after
King G3 is not that easy and Wesley has
some time to think about it this one
might actually be over very soon right
it's just a check check-in
pick up the uh pick up the bishop
pick up the pieces yeah yeah
uh by the way is time a factor at this
moment five players around uh the one
minute Mark Alice has uh just over one
another one once again and a half this
is the current position where we're
expecting either your C7 or uh Queen
takes uh G2 and queen ghx same idea
picking up this loose Bishop the bishop
which will be loose after capturing the
rook in C7 check
on the board King C8 only move not what
Alice really giving away that she's not
happy that she's resigned herself
to the loss by the way is
Rook no Rook C5 what am I saying Bishop
takes C5 so yes Queen takes G2 Bishop
takes C1 and we do see this geometry
of picking up the bishop
psychologically when you see this type
of easy ways out that gives give you a
decisive Advantage I think you just
simply go for it absolutely
because you're not risking anything
right right
Queen G8
this is the current position there's no
chance for the queen to get herself
per petrol no no I mean the bishop on E1
is going to be a Nifty Defender so
yep
I was just trying to be my irritating
best but I think you just actually just
walk up the board
and uh
you know you have your own threats yes I
do we should try to see what checkmate
and I don't think there's anything close
to her but can even hide my king behind
the F7 pawn and the arena going right
for that Bishop
so we're expecting King B
a this is the current position Queen is
on C4 check as she's picking up the
bishop on C1
D7
excuse me
King D7
I guess Atlas is saying that in case I
make a Perpetual I don't want to see you
you you can get to F7 or something like
that so she does go uh
King D7 I guess Queen H3 if I
both we're going to
we're going to both games at the same
time
how is the Wesley so in hikara Nakamura
because here this one is just going down
yeah and it's going to be an extra piece
for arena after the move uh we whoa whoa
whoa whoa we've got there's a rook on C6
uh Wesley what's going on Wesley played
B6 and said okay
if we go into that King and pawn end
game I'm ready to play C5 and I think
I'm better
Hikaru said I agree with you I'm not
going to go into any King and pawn end
game
and this is our current position
who's playing for a win and why what's
going on here
well there's there's only black that can
play for a win the problem is that you
don't have a good way to make any
progress
the only way for white to play for a win
is to bring another attacker to the
nitron F6 but there's no way to do that
he's played Queen to F1
I don't just
came to H2
how do you make any progress
do you still Queen a forking H3 and we
just repeat the position what happens if
you get greedy how quick takes B6 ah you
want to take another Pawn okay that's
fine
Jovi we're going to make
but now you're just a monster out I
think you lose right now it's
problematic I go Queen H1 Queen H1
followed by Queen E1 yes and now if you
go to H2 I take on H4 and I go to H3 I
go Queen E3 don't touch yeah it's
poisoned it's because the Rook is on a
dark Square
and now I have this double attack
Queen F1 on the board records to E6 on
the board a similar idea just keep the
Rook on the light Square
and there's no no Perpetual Urban
not more than Perpetual but why do you
say that
why do you say that white can't play for
the win I mean how do you play for a win
as well I'm
I'm dreaming of Rook
I mean of course I don't want to allow
Queen H1 but I'm dreaming that I somehow
could play King H2 and Rook G3 and like
a single go yeah good luck
so how does did you yeah six
and black is going to play Queen F4
Queen F1 Queen F4 Queen F1 Queen F4
it does yeah there's no there's no way
to make any progress for either side
again Rook G3 your idea Queen H1 that's
a Checkmate so yeah and if you do try to
go with let's say King so let's put
something on the board Queen F4
Rook C6 Queen F1 King H2
say that maybe after a queen F4 you have
Rook G3
and I cannot take on H4 because of Rook
to H3
but I believe I can move my king now
right King H5
yeah that's not something that white
would want to see the king getting out
of this uh absolute pin
so we think Queen F4 and four minutes
for uh
Wesley I I must say again that Sergeant
slow and suddenly turned into a bit of a
drama it has it has yeah it definitely
has and meanwhile it looks like Irina is
going to
winning her game any moment now
no Queen F4 we actually had Queen F2
Queen to F2 is that right yeah Queen to
F2
and the same idea I just keep my Rook on
the light squares I go Rook C6 rookie
six
well defending the pawn
Rook C6
I kind of like the fact that both sides
have this kind of
Mutual yeah
how many alternatives for either side
and again and the car was shaking his
head like the worst thing in life has
befallen him
it's a draw
where did I miss my chance and then he's
going to be informed no you were lost in
what really I can tell you one thing
Wesley is going to be super upset about
this situation missing queen queen
missing queen of faith
Wesley also he he's making these
intimations that he's not completely I
mean
happy with the outcome as himself like I
mean he blew it I what
it's been a strange game it has been a
very strange game but you know I guess
if your opponent is doing these
performances of displaying that they're
unhappy I think it's a nice tactic to
also do the same right
um like a queen F2
well he's touched his Queen so he's
definitely going to go Queen F1
or we I think we're going to see the
Dark of The Rook dance from e66 Queen
we check
King H2
well I think Queen F4 check would be the
one that would secure
the draw absolutely absolutely right
Queen F4 check King H3 Queen E3 check
yes yeah yeah
you have to
understand exactly because you can't
block the G3 because oh King H5 that is
actually a very
uh
Pleasant move to get out of this pin and
also uh okay can we try to lose with
black absolutely so how do we do it best
Queen F4 King H3 Queen E3
well that's the that's the that's the
line now Rook G3 yeah that was the line
I was trying to set up
and that's the resignation a resignation
as Arena crash continues her lopsided
score with Alice Lee in classical chess
our congratulations to Arena defending
Champion she's telling her you're still
too young
your future is bright but not today not
yet not today well this does put
honestly in the unenviable position of
needing to win tomorrow's classical game
to take the match to tiebreak and if she
wants to be the winner of the American
Cup she also needs to win the playoffs
and the games big ask big ass Sunday
a big ask indeed as she will be
challenged to win on demand tomorrow
Queen age
that is a pretty stale thing oh that's
nice oh that's a great shame on us for
not having spotted that ourselves uh
it's not I think I was telling him hey
what about Quincy Stefan Queen F7 it's
not common to see a stalemate with one
two three pawns on the board and a night
and a night very very very nice what a
finish and both games finished within
minutes of one another too
wow uh Queenie so for those of you who
are joining us late in the first game
between our championship match bracket
uh there was an opportunity for Wesley
so and it came about 20 minutes ago or
less as this first game was drawn I'm
bringing uh to your attention this
position and we just seen the pawn
promote to a queen queen takes check and
King H2 that was actually the losing
move that was remarkably enough King F2
would have drawn the game King H2 would
have lost should have lost the game
thanks to the move Queen C7 check
followed by Queen F7 and this makes all
the difference in the world
for you guys yes let's try to be humans
yes what if I go King F2
and now I try to win with queen of faith
I'm not going to look at the engine I I
don't want to see
well the Knight is pinned right I I just
want to go Queen F7
Queen F7 is the idea yeah yes now the
king of Pawn ending is not that clear
because the king is closer to the center
so let's go for it let's go for it yes
that makes the most sense
can I play G4 here well I can go King G7
and that's going to force you yes
exactly thank you yeah well let's do it
in the forcing manner well they
'll step up with you okay I'm a little
bit worried about H5 so Chief yeah
right King E5 and now the king comes B6
B6 and this is our problem let's try it
let's make that past Pawn
G
but what I wanted to do after qg7 there
is one more way to move that you should
improving move that you can make so here
you can go King King F3 you just have to
make sure the Knight can't Dodge away
from the pin that's a good point that is
a very good point indeed any h5s I mean
we like two can play the waiting game or
then you want to go Rook check and Rook
back no I think it's their H5 I just
take and I go G4 and I create the passer
and that should be enough right
you mean this way yes take take and G4
right fair fair
wow uh uh great stuff and both of of
these two great players are looking at
what turned out to be quite a remarkable
game it's a fascinating it really was it
really really really was the players are
just showing us why we all love chess
you know they're just trying to figure
out the truth the truth of the physician
yes as well
and the bishop was on A1
and there we see uh suno uh this is in
fact ridiculous and Hikaru is saying
yeah I don't get it either
wow what a what what a game and uh so so
I just saw it with the engine of course
uh check this out check it out after a
queen to have faith the only move to
make a draw is King F3
what queen F7 and now I just defend my
Rook
wow
and it's some sort of a setup where you
go here but now you don't have any
checks because my king is on the light
squares actually you do still have this
check now you're better
I'm not sure what's happening here guys
came to F3 king queen to F7 Rook to E5
and if you go King to G6 now I just give
you a check and I go back
what if I go King to G7
rookie seven now rookie seven and that's
a win yeah
wow
and if you go B6
G4 and now you actually have a thread G4
G5
yeah this is this is not mine not for
humans not for humans this whole
um fight I want to say of the queen
versus the two Rooks really challenge my
own perceptions of uh these endings
because I thought when you had the two
Rooks and the opposing King was
vulnerable give me the two Rooks right
and uh we saw that it was actually in
this particular case Wesley who could
have won the game I would I I really
really really uh stunned by by that
where as we get our players in the
studio to ask them what they thought of
their games I mean I think they're going
to be a little bit surprised as well uh
Jovi
pardon me uh and Christian we have again
Irina once again you come here laughing
and smiling and being super happy this
was a pretty good game but it wasn't
easy because she surprised you early on
with this idea of e for giving up the
pawn she was piling on the pressure on
you early on yeah well um she did say in
her interview yesterday that she was
going to rethink her match strategy and
she definitely came with something
different today I was really really
surprised at the opening because
basically let's put a few moves on the
board
yeah let's move E4 I mean I'm a sicilian
player is black and you think like if
you saw something like you know E4 C5
that F3 96 and you played Knight of six
you got an extra move as black would
white ever go E5 I mean you don't see
that you know so I mean of course at
first I thought I was like is she just
confusing things because I've never I
don't even think I've ever played Knight
F3 before yeah it's quite interesting
that she had this preparation in a line
that um she really couldn't have even
expected for me right
um I think perhaps it was prepped for
some other players yeah I mean my guess
would be would be it was it's prep for
me you know
um it's interesting choice you know
because the thing is of course it was
very uncomfortable for me to be like
surprised in the opening have her
playing instantly
um and I was quite slow and just trying
to understand the idea I was like well I
haven't made any mistakes so like here
go blacko is sacrificing the pawn how is
this going to work out let's pick it up
yeah
and then you think about where your
night should go I mean should you go to
D C3 or G3 but ultimately yeah I didn't
want to let the pawn get to D4 with
Tempo how did you come up to the
conclusion that you have to give this
check or that you want to give this
check well my first instinct I mean I
guess from a while back I was thinking
of probably 92 but then I was ultimately
like you know I really should be
developing my pieces and I didn't see
you know why not develop that bishop and
I mean it did cause her to think it's
interesting and maybe because it's
supposedly not a good move by the engine
like it gives black already an advantage
does it but you know
it's in
I understood this like I understood
there's positions in chess like where
the computer will say oh it's great for
black but the computer's idea of
compensation and initiative is not a
humans exactly and if a human cannot
find these moves it doesn't matter you
know so and that was my feeling was like
oh okay so now she's out of her
preparation you know and there's so many
choices for black right like there's
should you drive the pawn into H3 should
you go A6 yes Bishop D6 which Queen G5 I
mean so many moves right so I mean I
think in in this situation
um you know the computer evaluation at
home does doesn't help blacks and she
went the Stray very quickly after uh
with the move Bishop to D6 castle and
now you're already better yeah here
um I played what was it F3 yeah I mean
D4 Castle's Queen side I guess this is
the critical moment right if we go back
the question is can I get after Castle's
Queen side can I get in the movie E4 and
you know ultimately I just felt like it
was too loose you know and you know
there there is some crazy move H3 I
don't really know what's going on with
h3e5
um okay 95 okay well I'm not surprised
it is pretty crazy crazy's crazy
position but even if she goes like
without age three if she goes like uh
Pawn takes pawn queen E7 like even this
I really wasn't very sure about I mean
just because the pawns are hanging in
the center yeah it feels like like
you're using your extra Pawn but
actually you're also creating play for
black on the D file lots of tactics lots
of file diagonals so I mean okay I'm
glad to see that the computer agreed
that I shouldn't go for this because I
was certainly thinking about Bishop D2
was definitely the right choice in the
position just slowly build up your
attack and I really like the fact that
you let your knight stay on E2 yeah
don't go to C3 because you're probably
going to have to come back after the
move G5 you anticipated this move G5 let
me tell you actually when she played
Bishop C7 I was a bit unhappy like I'd
already kind of seen this idea but I was
like oh now she is gonna force me to
play a four like the same type
positional move I'm gonna have this bad
dark squared Bishop so I was definitely
concerned
when I saw Bishop C7
um but ultimately okay like you know I
blocked the bishop with F4 yes and I
still have this extra Pawn she cannot
trade the light squared Bishops yet
there's play against her King as well so
it felt okay like uh not a disaster
let's say an F4 I I think at this point
you are already kind of cruising yeah so
she she decided to play very bravely
giving up that well I don't know who's
Brave me and taking it or her and giving
it up but like you know she gave up this
Pawn on uh D5 and
um it just wasn't enough yeah oh no that
wasn't our game Christian excuse me Rook
to G6 at this point yeah yeah I'd have
to be a little bit careful here oh there
was some there were a lot of like ways I
could go wrong can I just show you one
of them like I mean her whole trick is
that if I go like a move back two moves
back with a pawn still on a2b2 if I go
D5 right like 95 yes I mean that's a big
trick in the position and you definitely
don't want to fall for that because I
guess you guys maybe looked at things
like that but I mean I actually get
myself mated very sad
um you know D5 was like my main idea but
then there was this big obstacle in
playing it so I had to like completely
um
completely reorient myself and find like
a different plan which I guess was was
pretty decent which you did it was in
fact the best way forward now you're
facing her again tomorrow with the black
pieces all you need is a draw to get the
title how do you feel about your chances
what are you going to do are you going
to do anything differently yeah yeah I
think um I will just play my game and
and play the same way I've been playing
all my games and you know hopefully
that's going to be good enough
congratulations Irina we'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
as well Arena as she continues her
winning ways she's a very very
impressive and a very good situation as
well because of course if she beats
Alice
if she beats Alice tomorrow
then then uh she will just win she will
be the American Cup winner absolutely uh
back to back uh impact as he is the
defending Champion but a draw is enough
a draw is enough yes exactly yeah no I
was thinking about for plett high breaks
and playoffs and then there will be a
winner that's true but we have uh also a
special guests in studio
a man who really who really uh pushed us
to our limits and I don't think we
understood this game very well maybe he
understood it a lot better than us yeah
I can't wait to hear his thoughts I mean
it's just so complex
and we're with Hikaru right now
Christian take it away hey Carl what
started as a slow paced game turned into
this complete mess complete drama tell
us the story of this game yeah I mean
well that's my you know last time I was
here and I played this E4 line was the
2019 us championship against sam7
um who I played here as well and
I mean it's kind of similar situation in
this game is that one where my opponent
got the double pawns Wesley from these
pawns on B6 and B5 and I thought it was
just a little bit better in the middle
game but it kind of well I mean I think
Wesley played very well first of all
that has to be said
um
but yeah let's keep going
uh foreign
no but I mean no so go back he didn't
play Bishop D4 at all got it ah okay
wait wait wait wait oh you're Diva yeah
it's like preparation for Fabiano or
something no no no no no this was your
game oh no I just see the sidelines so I
thought I mean maybe you're already
doing more well you do your commentary
um there we go yeah I mean it was a
solution that I thought I was a little
bit better but it's very it's very hard
to judge I mean I have the easy move so
Wesley is the one who had to come up
with uh sort of the ideas
um in the middle game and then I just
started getting wildly out of control
like I I mean there were a couple
options first of all he didn't play
Queen G4 but if you but but let's just
keep going with the game because there's
you know so many interesting moments um
yeah now he played he didn't go Queen G4
again he played uh
okay we're having some problems because
this should be updated it doesn't matter
I mean I I remember the whole game so
but the thing is like see so when he
played rookie I thought he might play B5
and I spent some time looking or when
Wes I was thinking I was thinking about
B5 and then he played rookie eight F4
and then B5 and I thought this order was
imprecise but somehow Wow Computer just
doesn't give much I mean it felt very
good for me like it feels like I'm
trying to do my best Bobby Fischer
impersonation with a good Bishop versus
a bad Knight
um and I thought everything I did was
logical I thought C5 was correct it was
the best move and he was defending I
mean I I somehow yeah I played Rook C1
which I thought was also the best move
then he played C6 and yeah and here also
I have a tough decision do I take on D6
or do I play F5 it means it's very hard
to judge so after F5 Queen two let's
just say E7 I don't know what's going on
I mean I can take on D6 and play
something like G4 but at the end of the
day
I figure if I'm not getting D4 in the
center here and I'm just pushing pushing
the p on the king side with G4 G5 then
like it's hard to believe this is a real
Attack I mean it looks I mean either
it's great or it's really stupid one way
or the other and I just thought it
didn't make a whole lot of sense from a
general standpoint like why do I want to
go for this
um so I try to keep it under control and
I thought everything I did was good
wow zero is crazy so I go Queen F2 and
then once they played F6 which I thought
was a good move and yeah it was real
pity because when I spent all my time in
this position to play D4 he takes F4 I
was gonna go Queen takes off four Queen
takes E4 takes takes D5 but I completely
missed Rook A6 here completely missed
this move um because if black plays Rook
C8 instead then I have rook fe1 and I
mean maybe it's still a draw anyway but
the Rook is getting in yeah but if you
put the Rook on A6 he has to find
through the eights yeah but I mean no
but the point is on Rook A6 go back to
D5 or k6 yeah yeah the problem is on
Rook A6 now when I go rookie one you I
mean you can just take on D5 stars but
you can even just trade the Rooks just
just to or no you can't sorry no you
have to take on D5 first and now now
yeah D6 is hanging at the end so it
doesn't work so then I have to go for
this whole yeah this whole crazy line
but it's very principled of course with
E5 very forcing
um
yeah of course now I open up the bishop
rookie one Queen D5 and I play Queen E2
here I mean
I mean in retrospect considering there
was no second time control probably if I
could do it again I would have played
like Bishop E5 or Rook D1 and just made
a draw but
um I I kind of I I felt like going for
it so I played Queen E2 and I think it's
like this move yeah but after I just
take I thought this is actually the same
thing oh Knight G6
like G6 yeah I mean because yeah this is
why it's still equal no I know but this
is why compute this is why computers are
so good because I didn't even consider
this I only saw an ic4 Knight D3 to get
back to the center I didn't see this
Knight G6 line but yeah yeah it's still
I mean it's it's wild because he goes
Knight C4 and I I just assumed that
after takes takes King F7 there has to
be some kind of puzzle here some kind of
big study with rookie seven but I mean
it still says zeros which is insane
because after King G6 takes I mean
originally I wanted to go Bishop C3
after King H6 no no Rook two seven keep
going yup King H6 I want to go Bishop C3
Bishop C3 yeah
but then there's Knight to E3 and if I
play Rook C1 I think there's Knight two
D1 that's the problem there's Knight D1
and now now the Knight is jumping and
yeah I mean I saw this
um you know another one that I also
consider was Bishop F6
Queen takes D6 and G4 but I think after
just Knight E3 I don't I don't have a
Checkmate like it looks really good but
there's no Checkmate yeah yeah ah I have
Rook G8 though
oh I have this one
ah this is just a drawer yeah I mean
probably okay no but I mean it's still
this is another beautiful mating concept
with the pawn on G4 to go Rook G8 Bishop
G5 because the only mating construction
I saw was with H4 Rook G5 I didn't I
didn't see this one with G4 Bishop G5
this is actually beautiful yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I mean I I didn't so yeah
so I I use a lot of time Play Bishop a
one I should just play this instantly
rather than burning like 15 minutes
um yeah Wesley played Knight E3
which is a blunder or something yes or
ah so H4 actually is winning what well
sort of knight uh H4 I think Queen D3
was played Yeah so basically I played as
quicker maybe I would have found it but
the thing is like here I was down to
like seven minutes yeah he goes Queen D
wait wait a second what king H3 is the
best no wait no no wait a second wait
wait a second why is King is stupid
Queen takes D6
I mean I was gonna play King H original
but there's Queen takes D6
Knight D5 oh I have Bishop f8 no wait
what are you sure
yeah
no no actually I saw no no I I actually
saw this but I was I saw this with the
other order with Rook F5 I did very
briefly see his takes five but then King
G6 Bishop B5 Queen E6 yeah I very
briefly saw this but this one I'm losing
yeah no more oh yeah yeah I mean if I
have 20 minutes me maybe I can find this
but still it's very very easy yeah yeah
yeah I think for half a second yeah I
did I did see this but I only saw I work
F5 I didn't see the other order with
Bishop E5 first but I mean all right
like I'm not stock fish so like this is
really asking asking for a lot but you
did play King 12 too that's fine yeah
but this was also based on a complete um
misunderstand yeah I did see Rook F7
which draws but I mean at this point I
when I went King F2 because I saw I mean
if I saw King issue Queen G6 request of
Knight D5 and G3 takes Rook F6 which
should be a draw so when I when I went
for this at this point after
sorry you took on A1 yes
already at this point when I won King F2
I thought okay I'm going for it no
matter what I'm I'm gonna try to win but
of course without a second time control
and only like a couple of minutes it's
impossible this two is drawing wow yeah
after G5 is no but I I thought I mean I
thought I just blundered this because
after a night he played 95 yeah D7 Queen
h8 yeah
yeah now I played yeah I played rookie
four which is I mean this was just a
huge blunder because I missed um
because we both thought that Wesley was
okay we both thought thought that I mean
Wesley and I both thought that he was
winning yeah because basically after
Queen House of King G1 like I spent like
all my time calculating worksheet five
and it was to get to this line when and
I thought Queen E6 I have rookie six and
I just you know I just won the game but
there's plenty one Queen yeah so like
when I spent my five minutes I was
looking at like Queen h8 with Knight C7
and all kinds of craziness and I think I
thought I was probably winning there but
um yeah so I make the queen and this
this is still a draw and you were
shaking your head at this point
[Laughter]
yeah somewhere around here I already
like I thought I just thrown the game
but
uh so if I go to F2 G3 it's still so
that's why you were shaking your head
you thought you were lost at this point
yeah I mean I I because because the
whole thing was I thought I had this
rookie 68 Queen I win the game so when
there's Queen Essence Queen D6 it's
already feels very bad but King Asia
yeah and Wesley gone Queen C7 did you
spot yeah I thought after Queen C7 maybe
I have some some weird attempt with like
King H3 oh but there's there's Queen D7
yeah that's the problem because I think
I thought King H3 Queen F7 rookie five
was still maybe some chances because now
I have some G4 or something yeah I guess
Queen D7 wins anyway but it feels like
there might be some attack here yeah
yeah and then fortunately I mean Wesley
didn't do this he played the uh the
obvious move which is Queen D4 he's a
very practical move right Queen to D4
yeah queen of Faith apparently was
winning as well but yeah but it's hard
to go into zen game with Queen office
yeah and then after fortunately I
spotted King G3 and now I think it's
it's still a draw so yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's very very very very strange
game I mean I I guess we both actually
played pretty well I mean I I don't
think I mean it's hard for me to really
be disappointed because there's there is
that one win with King issue but I mean
that's really
I mean I I just didn't see the the move
order sequence because I did see Rook F5
Rook F5 there should be five Queen E6
with that one I think I'm losing so
that's what it is crazy game today
tomorrow with the black pieces uh what
do you expect from Wesley yeah I mean
it's I I don't know I I think at this
point I've done what I came here to do
which is not lose rating points so you
know just just play and see what happens
but I think on the bright side at least
people should should have enjoyed this
game today oh yeah it was a great game
Hikaru congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
thank you uh great game just absolutely
great game mesmerizing in fact and uh
all the head shaking also was confusing
for us like did he think he Boo the win
did he think he he made a loss I mean we
were going back and forth in our
conjectures but there was so much
content going on in that game it was
really really uh special and I mean so
many Maneuvers that's possible and it
just like it's the perfect kind of game
to decide a championship this is the
type of game that we want we don't want
to see the guys just making draws and
going to some playoffs which they think
will favor them one way or another but
really you know put us under the
microscope but we still have uh tomorrow
in front of us yes we do because we have
another class game another remember if
the match is tied then we will see
playoffs right and there are two people
who are in a must win situation and by a
win I mean they must win the match
overall it's Wesley so and Alice Lee if
they win the match then the whole
tournament continues until Sunday
wonderful
and Wesley is uh with a Christian to
explain what was going on in his mind
that's a good question the answer to
start off with what was going on in your
mind Wesley were you thinking that you
might have chances to win that game at
any point or did you just sing and play
for a draw now with just playing chess
huh playing chess yeah no but actually I
thought the winning move would move 40
like I was I had 10 minutes and I
totally saw it you did say queen C7 yeah
I mean I was gonna play but I thought
Wendy four wins do I just forget that
this game can advance all the way to F4
E5 play it's a big bitty but at the same
time it's not like I was winning the
entire game and he had a chance you
played a very good defensive game up to
that point because the problem
for example after King G1
Queen F4 which I just missed and then I
just think does Queen F7 still win or
Queen F7 I thought rook ge5 and I'm
being and if not so easy not so easy
you have to but I miss queen F4 I mean I
saw the pin but also after Queen C7
after G3
Queen F7 Rook G5 King G7 I forgot that
after seven I have Knight G4
I should have played it but the sermon I
missed so many chances so just part of
life but at the same time happy that uh
because apparently I made some mistakes
couple mistakes in the game but he was
it seems like he was better at one point
but it was indeed very very difficult
this moment he could have played this
move Rook to E7 I'm not even sure if the
years
yeah yeah it's really crazy because um
the game was so complex
and uh made a couple Miss I think we
both made a couple of mistakes here and
there but um
um no it's not so easy with limited time
it's been very very difficult to get a
victory in this tournament especially
against uh Hikaru it's always difficult
to get a victory what are you going to
do differently to try to get that result
tomorrow
[Music]
well try to
not mess up try to get an advantage you
know and
try to try to play well
I mean today had a big chance for one
move
but uh
yeah at the same time he had like
millions of throws before that yeah it's
nothing
so just you know I'm just happy to still
be in the tournament but the car is very
good player I'm surprised he's doing so
well even though he spends 24 7
streaming but
yeah I would if I was him I wouldn't be
able to play this well and create so
much content well lastly you got to know
Hikaru so personally in this tournament
as well you've played already a very
long match against him what do you feel
his strengths weaknesses are can you
describe Hikaru as a player yeah
well he's been playing really well over
the last
year over the almost over the last two
years uh
uh he's
he's doing so well like in the Grand
Prix also some rapid in the St Louis
rapid and Blitz also all the classical
tournaments that he played in uh well
he's very good he's very well prepared
in the opening first of all yes his
second long time second Chris little job
but how does he do it because you just
mentioned he streams 24 7. how does he
still maintain that preparation yeah I
mean
obviously Johnny Thurman I guess he
memorized a lot you know he prepares
with a super computer with the second
you know and then before the tournament
I think he works on his General Chester
uh for sure you know he sold out pastels
I guess he looks at games too but you
gotta ask him for more comprehend
absolutely but I mean in speed chess
he's uh definitely in top two or tapped
in the world yeah sir Jovi yeah quick
question for you USA first of all I
thought it was a great game seriously uh
oh uh we really really enjoyed
commentating the game I just wanted to
ask you your opinion about the head
shaking at the very end did you
interpret that as
as uh Hikaru
blundering the game to a loss or
blundering the game to a draw when he
saw him shaking his head was he
indicating to you that he had given up
he let the victory slip by or
yeah he probably didn't see the the in
the beginning like this King Jitter King
at 14 E5
because uh I bet he's talking h27 and
black wings
but um
he probably thought he was losing at one
at some point
um
and he had very little time he had three
minutes
and well I played the car many years as
I said before when he's shaking his head
that means you're in very big terrible
no actually it's the opposite when he's
shaking his head then
you know that's when he starts looking
for most chances like in the rapid in
the first rapid game he started shaking
his head also but then he was playing
for a win then he found all the best
moves so he's the Civic no he's taking
his help no I totally deceiving when
he's shaking his head you know that he's
looking for all the tricks
but you know it is what it is I mean I
don't really
I I think it's my fault for not playing
Quincy 7 playing 24 to too quickly but
um
I'm I was also getting very tired you
know I'm the only player who didn't have
a rest day here so it's not so easy to
play four or five hours
uh every single day and then you also
have to prepare a little bit so that's
why I have to be in good physical shape
we'll let you get your rest Wesley uh
we'll look forward to the game tomorrow
and again I think it was a great game
also very happy birthday to you yeah sir
hey thank you thank you I'm just looking
for a lot of serious cash okay
serious cash birthday presents
he only takes cash in a briefcase you
don't want cakes or cupcakes huh well I
got cupcakes I got the cupcakes covered
with the cash serious serious cash out
the door Wesley thank you Wesley good
luck to borrow and thank you Esther nice
uh what a super finals we have grand
finals we've had as Arena wins uh puts
the pressure once again uh on Alice and
these two guys they're such Gladiators
great boggling and it was just an
amazing thing you said first day I have
to say of the Grand Final and Christian
what do you think about today's day of
action oh just an incredible day of
action I have to say I'm mightily
surprised by the way this game between
Wesley and Hikaru developed uh
pleasantly surprised I have to say and I
think there's still a lot of fight left
between these two players and that
matchup between Irena and Alice Lee
honestly will have a great chance with
the white pieces try to come back in
this match tomorrow and we will be here
to call all the action guys I've been
having a lot of fun and I think you guys
have been having a lot of fun as well so
I'll see you guys tomorrow absolutely
and we hope that you've been enjoying
yourself and if you have tell your
friends where you're hanging out and
we'll see you all tomorrow
same place good night good night good
night
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited